hello hello whoa we haven't had a 7 p.m stream in a long
time but i really really want to make progress on god of war
i i do not we do not want a repeat of last god like of the
last god of war series where it took me almost a year to
finish god of war so i'm trying my best and i've and you
know, this God of War 2 and God of War, well, it's really
hard to see what the number of it, because it's not
technically God of War 5, it's like God of War Ragnarok is
longer than the last God of War, so we gotta make as much
progress as we can.
I might do a long stream today.
I don't know, I'm not sure.
I mean, tomorrow I don't have a stream tomorrow.
I'm just, uh, I'm literally like uh recouping from this hell
month in general so um we're so close to the end of hell
month uh because after the pubg tournament uh on after
monday i will be free i'm i will be free no more obligations
um no more well for now no more special announcements for a
while for a while so we can relax for the next couple of
weeks we can we can relax and I'm looking forward to it oh
my god I forgot lunar new year I forget um never mind never
mind we still have lunar new year I'm sorry all the holidays
have been blurring together for me now so I'm it's like
because it's like back to back to back to back holidays um
or special of special streams because we have It never
stops.
Lunar year is just around the corner.
To be fair, this month just had so many special events and
everything.
That like I forgot.
I actually do have a special event stream on Lunar New Year.
But after Lunar New Year.
No more.
No more special surprises or special events or anything.
It's just normal streams for a while.
Until the next special event stream.
My brain is so fried right now.
Viction, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Generally, you're one of the best VTB streamers I know, and
I value you.
You're the best.
And thanks for streaming my birthday.
Happy birthday, Viction, and thank you for joining today's
stream.
Thank you again.
Oh, sorry.
I was supposed to think happy birthday.
And I was like, I'm going to say thank you first for the
super chat.
Thank you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear.
fiction happy birthday to you yeah happy birthday um wrench
thank you for super chat thank you thank you hey doke you
can't stay but i want to still support the live stream catch
the vibe at work i'm glad you're enjoying the game despite
the link thank you for super chat thank you day i've been
enjoying the game a lot really like the i think the writing
and the voice acting is really really good for ragnarok um
and also the graphics too the uh the lore building that
they're doing is really good so far especially when we're
like at 50 of the story uh but i love the lore building that
they are establishing for us.
And like the little plot, like the little twist and turns in
the story.
NSD, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hello.
Hey, Adoki.
Hope your hell week isn't going too bad.
It was my birthday yesterday.
Sorry, I'm late.
I'm a yearly required payment.
Thank you for the super chat.
NSD, thank you.
Thank you.
And I hope you have a great birthday.
You had a great, oh my gosh.
Oh, sorry.
My AI is malfunctioning right now.
It's like the smoke is coming.
out of the ram sticks right now um and i see uh again thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you happy birthday to
you happy birthday to you happy birthday dear and i see
happy birthday to you yeah happy birthday yeah oh my gosh so
many birthdays today yeah you got ram yeah i'm storing ram
in my brain i haven't sold it yet for like uh 90 profit also
i i've been Craving Overwatch lately because it was so fun
when we did that preview stream a couple of days ago It was
so fun But then I was looking at Twitter and everyone was
saying how Jetpack Cat has been banned almost every rank
game because of all the bullshit that he can pull I don't
know if you guys saw but he can pull he basically pull every
alt in existence So he can pull Deva alt he can pull Reaper
alt he can pull Bob You don't even ask Bob's consent to
touch him like
you don't even need to ask his consent you could just lift
him up um but yeah apparently he's been like uh he's been
banned almost every rank game in every elo um so i was like
the only reason why i want to play overush is just to play
the cat but in he's been banned so many times that the
official overwatch twitter account was like please stop
banning the cat like for they give the super chat me really
happy catching all the sugar games you played this week
thanks for keeping me comfy while it's working of course of
course i'm glad everybody's been enjoying um this week's
upstream i can't believe it like we played uh you know we
revisited all my exes and my uh and my current flame
everything and they all understand by the way they all
understand not three-timey any of them guys by the way they
they we have an agreement uh forward thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you i'm glad that everybody's had a
great time watching uh watching the streams uh 14 thank you
for super chat thank you thank you hey toky can you say uh
whatever that is in iron fist style okay i need to translate
i need to translate this because i don't know i can't read
i'm sorry
uh uh
qi guan chang hong there Chihuan Chang Hong.
Yeah, there you go.
That, oh yeah, that's, is that, oh, that's the alt.
That's, I'm sorry, I've been hearing everyone saying the,
like, the English way of saying it that I forgot the Chinese
way.
Any, yeah, that's the alt.
You know, everyone always call it a cheaper town hall.
Like, that's how I associate the alt now because that's what
everyone says.
I'm like, oh, shit, that's the official, that's the official
way.
It's been so long since I heard this uh they call it they
call it cheap uh cheaper town hall um whenever like any rank
player or pro player use iron fist all they um they always
shout out cheaper town hall and it's now so ingrained in my
head that i legitimately forgot what the official what the
official alt line is uh
a war time let's go oh my gosh also i just found out you
know how it's actually crazy that they announced a remaster
uh or like not remastered the remakes actually uh the
remakes of god the original god of war trilogy i thought it
was really funny that after they announced that they
announced the prequel of uh god of war and then the voice
actor is kid itchorus
What's the word?
It's just like, oh, man, like a huge, like a little, like,
what the fuck?
Why is Kid Icarus created?
Kid Icarus before his family got killed.
Yeah, it was such a whiplash.
I was like, wait a minute.
Is that, is that Pitt?
Before, before like, you know, he was, he had, he's still at
hope and whimsy in his heart before the gods killed his
family.
Anyway, let's go play God of War.
Let's see if I can remember the controls.
It's a little fun game.
Will Doki Bird remember the controls?
Or will it take her five hours to figure everything out
again?
What a fun game.
Alright, 6.5.
What is that?
Is that the God of War?
Yeah, that is.
6.5.
Alright.
And then.
Here's my God of War stream.
Hello.
This is running.
Am I God of War?
Come on.
Azura, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Any plans on the upcoming Lunar New Year?
I really want to go to.
I want to go to.
I really want to go to like.
There's usually like Lunar New Year markets around town and
stuff.
I really want to go to one.
I want to see a lion dance.
It's been so long since I saw a lion dance live.
And I definitely want to go to one again.
I want to see the lions eat a cabbage.
I love it when you feed a cabbage to the lions.
And they go, I'm yum, yum, yum, yum.
It's one of my favorite parts.
And also like the...
when they do the little acrobat's and oh yes moon cakes I
love the ice cream moon cakes the most oh and they're like
they're my go-to I'm not a huge fan of the egg yolk ones but
I love the uh yeah they absolutely destroy that cabbage like
a cookie like cookie monster with cookies they're like yum
yum yum cabbage
um but my favorite I I personally I'm not because I'm not a
fan of egg yolk like um um in general uh so like even like
even like if it's just the yolk itself whenever i eat hard
boiled eggs i just eat the egg whites i literally just like
not even even if it's like that's why i only eat scrambled
eggs i don't even like sunny side up or anything because i
just hate the taste of yolk in general even if it's cooked
or like fully cooked or like semi-raw um i'm just not a huge
fan of the yolk itself so like i'm not so i would just every
time i eat like hard boiled egg Parents forced me to eat
hard-boiled egg.
I just, like, eat the egg whites on the outside and then
just, like, gave my mom, like, egg yolk, the yolk itself.
And also, like, so, like, for mooncakes, that's why I'm not
a huge fan of the egg yolk in the mooncake itself.
So every time, like, I get mooncakes, I always get the ice
cream version of them because they're so good.
Or, like, the mochi version.
Anyway.
more god of war time but uh but that's my like personal
plans for lunar new year um i think i'll definitely be doing
a stream for lunar new year um but not i don't know exactly
yet i have like a semi plan of it uh but not sure exactly
yet what we're gonna do if i had so many events back to back
to back to back to back wow i had so many stuff going on oh
my gosh i'm just glad that um things are dying down now
yeah i'm just like um i love the oh my gosh and marble
rivals recently released a new update for uh they uh they
released a new update to celebrate lunar new year and it
looks i really it looks so sick brother i know you guys saw
it but uh basically there's like a lion dance at the at uh
town square town square and also um like traditional lunar
new year music you hear about discord i heard people are uh
pulling up vr chat to pretend to do the identification of
discord it just could be like yes that is a real person like
Do you guys see that?
Or, gee, my brother, do you...
Yes, they're like, yes, this is a real person.
You pass.
Yes, you can do that.
You can pull up, like, a 3D model and just, like, and then
use it as the verification.
Like, it's like, what's the point?
Yo, yo, yeah, apparently someone used to have stranding.
Quiet.
She is a friend.
Better they get this from you.
Watch this.
Once the wolves have the scent of the norns, we'll just need
to follow their lead.
I will open the gate.
Oh, why are you whining?
Their fur is matted.
When did you last brush them?
They are wolves.
They don't need...
They don't need brushes.
They're woes.
They're not domesticated yet.
How the fuck were they able to clean their fur before I was
here, huh?
You don't need my help.
They're strong independent woes.
They are dogs.
That takes us hundreds of years.
Domestication is not that fast.
Also, do you guys hear people are slowly domesticating
raccoons?
Apparently, like, raccoons are showing...
signs of domestication how i may find my son i don't exactly
remember like what the traits were but like apparently uh
scientists are like yeah raccoons are now showing signs of
domestication demise you didn't tell me you had a death
prophecy when atreus and i reached yodenheim we found a
hidden mural the giants pay herself had foreseen our entire
journey long ago yeah what were the signs do you guys
remember i don't remember i just remember it on twitter
because that's how i get all my news now that image was from
a time yet to come i see you've never struck me as someone
who fears death that's not the problem is it no oh short and
snow oh yeah short and snow i don't understand what the
benefits are what's the what are the benefits for like the
snow to be shorter and you're still not sure why speak of
this no further is it because they look cuter so it makes
people want to take care of them more yeah i was gonna say
it i knew it i was like is it because like they're trying to
make themselves look cuter so people would give them more
food that makes so much it's like cats you know cats meow
just for humans right they don't actually use meows to
communicate in um to other cats meowing is just to make to
benefit the uh when there's barking and some increases when
nearing the source oh what is this yeah so they meow only
because uh only to make us like care for them more what is
this how do i do this again we don't have the equipment for
this oh
yeah it was for it's literally capped care baiting yeah they
only meow to us and make sure we take care of them or defeat
them they does have made themselves quite at home yeah
they'll leave me out at us so they could get fed by us she
speaks highly of that fight as well you know of that she
told me all about it when she found me out take care of me
I'm a cute cat and it works every time I'm the Valkyrie
Queen as Segrin was stubbornly determined to remind me I
don't fucking know where to go.
My dog is not barking excitedly.
He's so loyal.
Why?
Oh, what's that over there?
Mm-hmm.
Doesn't take a love goddess to see where you're coming from.
Oh, that's the portal.
The spread of fate we are tracing.
It's not somebody's life if that's what you mean.
The Norns use it to mark their way when they're outside of
the well.
The Norns live in a well.
No.
the well of earth their home is i don't know where to go
where's the compass it's in no fixed place entrances come oh
gosh a place holy under their influence that's over here
where the intangible becomes tangible bless me being inside
your own mind hold that thought i think it's about to get
violent oh my god i do not remember how to play this game
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine!
JK, I do remember!
Get out of here!
Oh shit, I did not mean to be...
Okay, alright, rage attack.
I did not mean to go full rage mode, okay.
We'll stop here.
Nice.
Is he okay?
Oh, he is not okay.
Oh, shit.
Hey.
What the fuck?
He's like, I'll take you down with me.
And then I just walked five steps back.
These were coal raiders.
Infamous for you.
Eating wolves.
Atreus and I rescued ours from such an encampment.
Oh.
Kind of you.
The coal raiders have been a plight on this land.
The way they've abused its creatures.
Oh, that's fucked.
something about that psychopathic behavior up to you brother
if the norms know the future we'll expect us to show up a
bit later oh my god wait did they think oh no my dog they're
just like remember to go back to where your dogs are okay
but where the fuck are the fates all right limited one okay
all right i got one of the cabs the norms domain is like
being inside your mind maybe here like the sound of that Is
this where I came from?
I don't know!
I'm looking at their ways of discouraging visitation.
I'm looking at their heads!
I wouldn't talk about what he found.
Alright, where is your head?
Okay.
Left!
Where is it?
Where is it, boy?
Right!
Alright.
Oh my god, the heads are compass, guys.
The head is compass!
Like waking up from a dream.
Forward.
Mainly, I remember that nothing could be done to change my
son's fate.
Which only made me more determined to try.
Okay forward.
Okay, but what's over here though?
Ooh.
What of your story?
Luke.
You face the fates of your homeland, yes?
Oh.
It's okay.
Oh, that's not okay.
I saved it for this!
Bam!
Okay, um, that's awkward.
I need you to be a little closer.
He's being a little closer so I can punch you
Okay, that's good
It's fine Oh fuck, I forgot you can't dodge that Oh fuck, I
can't, I forgot
Okay Okay, there you go, there you go, there you go There,
okay, there you go There, there you go And another Ah, shit,
okay, okay, okay, okay It's fine, it's fine Help me, help
me, help lady!
Why didn't she help me?
She just watched me get my shit kicked in!
Ma'am!
That's fucked up.
You all saw that.
She literally just watched me get myself beat up.
Like, I thought she was supposed to be an ally.
Come on, that's not fair.
Okay.
Oh, that's fine.
That's fine.
I'm slowly trying to remember.
Lock in, please!
There you go.
What?
How did I hit me?
Okay.
Okay, that's not fair.
That is actually not fair.
Please, ma'am.
Guys, I don't think I...
Okay, there you go.
There you go.
Oh, my God.
It's fine.
Come on.
How did you unlock yourself?
No!
Holy shit.
Okay, this guy is hard.
I swear to God, if this loot isn't worth it, I swear to
fucking God, I'm going to be so sad.
I'm going to save it, actually.
I'm just going to save it.
Fuck it.
There you go.
Oh, fuck.
I'm trying.
Please help me, ma'am.
Okay.
Oh my god.
lock itself again.
Are you fucking kidding me?
It's okay.
I have rage.
I can get my HP back with this.
Okay, it's okay.
Kept my rage for the HP.
It's worth it.
There you go.
I hate that.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh,
it's fine.
It's fine.
I'm getting better.
I'm getting better at it.
I'm figuring out the patterns.
Okay, there you go.
Oh, my God.
There you go.
Okay, there you go.
I'm getting better at the dodges, guys.
See that?
there you go are you fucking bitch oh my god you fucking
bitch oh my god you'll punch him now i need to start
punching i need more hate i need i'll win the hate why are
you just watching me did you see that she literally was just
watching me That's fucked!
I saw that, lady!
Okay, there you go.
There you go.
Oh, that's not fair.
A fucking course sheet like fucking...
Yeah.
Oh, thank God.
Okay, we did it.
Reminds me of tales of a cruel empress.
Oh, that was close.
Made it.
Fucking made it.
You weren't supposed to do that.
You weren't supposed to blow up.
Like, six to a story is true form.
Oh, my God.
I don't think I'm going to be able to collect.
Wait, what?
What is he doing there?
That's not where I left the dog.
Or is that the...
Ah.
Just a little pesky guys.
Now, brother.
What about when you face the fates of Greece?
The legends I heard about the ghost of Sparta were...
What the fuck is the angle on this?
Is that a player?
Oh, oh my god, that's nice.
It's like an Uber.
once lost it's strange stability obviously i mean a rumor
about thor knocking the world itself back in history from
ragnarok is one thing it is the truth the threads of fate
span all life and time like my uber wolves seems a fate
abused their power when i challenged them they threatened to
undo my existence so i killed them and turned their power on
zeus that's the most dangerous and irresponsible thing i've
ever heard these noons have no such magic Nor does anyone in
these realms that I've ever seen.
What's over here?
Wait, let us look this way.
Quiet.
What's over here?
Ooh, hidden region?
Wait, that's rainbow.
Why is the fire rainbow?
An abandoned kin.
Whoever was here left long ago.
Oh.
What did you find?
provisions needed to prepare a meal a recipe who left that
way out here yeah let's take a look at the ingredients oh is
this a side quest he will lead us to them rainbow fire okay
across the realms find the recipes ingredient okay is that
even worth it like i don't even know that's worth it looks
like initials there's like some do they match the ones and
that recipe book you found what imagine we might find one of
those ingredients around here oh is it right here right now
is there an ingredient here we're gonna do the cooking by
the book but on on on lazy town time all right let's just
see if wait do i have anything new actually Dades of Chaos.
No heavy yet.
Cyclone.
Wait, which is better?
I like this more, I think.
Explodey?
Explodey seems stronger in general.
Yeah, my shit's level 5 here, so it doesn't matter.
Wait, new amulet for this.
Wait, what?
Oh, I could put it on No, it's fine.
Can I upgrade my runic attack?
Oh, I can.
Oops.
I should really do that.
No, I did not realize this.
It was level...
It was level one.
It's awkward.
Oops.
Just to circle back and close the book on this, time travel
rubbish if it existed Odin would have it and if Odin had it
we'd be five shades more fucked than we are already hold let
us search this area what's over there wait was there
something over there oh yeah wait is this oh there it is ah
and you are recognized those initials the ballad of Yari and
Somar i'm not familiar an old tale but a good one
nonetheless
this realm nine out of ten always try and find the others if
you're curious oh my god another side quest oh my god how
many side quests oh no it's an ingredient okay are any of
the side quests worth it i'll i might i can do one finding
the norms is not about altering events yeah we'll call staff
all over again lali thank you super chat thank you thank you
seems the wolves have led us here i just hope the norms are
somewhere indoors i am warm safe to see this one is it okay
missed midgard and fumble winter thank you we will see soon
enough this is gonna be like there's gonna be half the world
in like 50 years sorry that might be too dark guys too edgy
damn oh
Token tab, true.
Ragnarok is just predicting the future.
Oh my god, where are you shooting at?
Alright, that's fine.
Actually...
Oh fuck, what the fuck!
Get out of here!
Oh no, I'm frozen.
I'm frozen right now.
Fires is strong against ice now.
That's what they told me.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
He's just, like, tanking it.
He doesn't care.
Holy shit, he does not care.
Okay, there's five.
It's five.
That's okay.
That's good.
That is good.
That's why I didn't kill them first.
Alright.
Where's the last guy?
See, I know my type advantage, guys.
Anyway, I really need heals.
Oh, God.
Splat.
Explode!
There you go.
See?
Fires put against.
Ice.
The way forward is magically sealed.
Something in here is giving it power.
Maybe this?
The hilt of a sword.
Brother, I know that sword hilt.
Tread carefully.
You of all people know how weapons can carry ghosts.
Oh.
Oh, we did it.
If it does not help us find the sword hilt of King Raki, is
a man worn as once contained great power.
Oh!
Hey, free stuff.
I feel a trace of their illusions here.
I can try to dismantle it.
Alright, nice.
Alright, greed, woman.
Wait, what's over here?
Okay, we gotta make the shortcut.
Okay, nice.
There's also a little portal too.
We'll have to see what else the wolves can find.
Typical Nornish mischief.
They know we're searching.
I warned you they wouldn't make it easy.
Oh, there's nothing here.
And what's the health of a cursed king?
I asked her to read because I'm illiterate and she's smarter
than me because she's a woman that can read.
I suppose they'd say we were fair.
And I'm man that go ungabunga.
My son didn't teach me how to read.
wait what do you guys think I said I said read woman so to
be clear finding the norms is not about altering events yeah
I only want information yeah what did you guys hear it's
this way the Vikings thought matters Half was woman's work.
Numbers hard.
Tell me more of your homeland.
It was violent and cruel.
Sounds no different from these lands.
It was warmer when mines.
Read disembodied head.
How come everyone knows how to read but me?
Too bad.
Tear has no interest in doing either these days.
that's crazy that's such a crazy statement what do the
vikings what what did the vikings know
all right we go this way
all right all right was kick me to the face what's that like
their heads i have to like stop to see where they're going
try this way the heads don't really turn that much what the
are you are you just fucking taking me into a circle where
are you taking me moves yeah oh my god well lady i was
curious about something okay straight travels and you will
remain look i go this way they don't turn around i'm so
confused oh you can see that again they just want walkies is
it here no it isn't i can't go anywhere Oh my god There must
be a magnet nearby or some shit That's fucking up my compass
Oh my god it was this path They turned to the left I tried
to go to this path And then their heads returning to the
left This is the area Oh my god these walls let's see I feel
something in this direction feel what exactly another
illusion it's coming from this wall the norms are hiding
something alright alright magic woman oh no yeah that's
being a dead end yeah so another dead end hi okay that that
scared me i was not ready for the i was not ready for this
guy i was just like oh shiny thing and a giant tiger came
along look i was not expecting it are you kidding me where
did he come from okay oh my god how do i change weapons oh
my god there you change weapons but I couldn't okay okay
that's fine wait how do I oh there you go oh my god not
another one no I feel so good oh nice I mean yeah fucking
course I'll start raging if I can jump-scared?
I'd be like, who the fuck was that?
It's like when you're at a haunted house and you have to
sign like a little weaver to be like, please, um, you know,
this search will only get more dangerous.
Whereas like, uh, you're not- We're like, if you
accidentally get the jump-scared actors, but can you try to
scare you and punch one of the actors?
And you're like, you're liable if you punch one of the
actors.
What is up here?
I don't feel anything.
It's not related to the Norns.
Could be interesting enough in its own right.
What's that outpost?
Oh, another hidden region.
Oh, hey!
At your service.
Was there anything good?
Not really.
I feel like I have all the good shit already.
Yeah.
Anything for Freya?
Uh...
I'll disinfect my tools.
I don't have any materials, too.
I'm broke.
I'm actually broke.
No, I looked.
I can't upgrade anything.
I'm sorry, but you'd have to ask Odin.
He's got control of every path.
I know how highly you esteem our expertise on such things,
so I'm sure that's disappointing.
He's just been one step ahead of us.
Okay, that's how you swap weapons.
Okay, I was trying to remember how to swap weapons.
I was like, I was like, anyways, I was smashing every button
except for, like, swap weapons.
I don't believe it, Namir.
This crest belongs to Fjotorloom.
Fjotorloom?
You see?
Now that's where Sikron was from.
What the loom?
Another crane.
Go!
Oh, we go this way.
Seems it only rotates in the other direction.
That's fine.
I made it to the other side.
What's this?
Oh, wait, this way.
Oh?
Wait, how do I kill this?
Oh, I just...
Bro...
That's how.
Dude, let me chuck my axe at it.
Wait, what the fuck?
Oh.
Oh, yeah, I need your arrows.
I thought it was all me.
I'm sorry.
I was like, damn, all me.
Alright, nice.
Alright, read.
Another sleeping troll, courtesy of the dwarves.
Alright.
They have free XP, though.
Is there anything over here?
Oh, no.
There has to be a shortcut for this.
Alright.
Then we go this way.
Yay!
Oh, loot!
So this outpost is what's left of Fjordland.
Seagrin spoke of growing up with these people before she
joined the Valkyries.
Oh, more loot.
Wait, how do I...
I have to move this here.
Yay, loot!
Okay, more crafting material.
I didn't need that.
Oh, how do I get over there?
Oh my god, I'm like in a side quest of a side quest right
now.
What the fuck?
Oh, what the fuck?
I was just watching!
What the fuck?
What the fuck am I not allowed to watch?
That's fucked up.
I was like, are you okay, lady?
Like...
I was just very concerned.
She was...
Wait, I was like, is there a doctor in here?
And then she exploded.
Okay, it's this way.
No, I can't already use it from here.
No, I have to push all the way up.
Yeah, I was trying to help, but now...
Now I guess you die.
See, guys, there's no benefits to helping people.
Look at that.
What was the point of helping, guys?
That's why I should never help.
What the fuck?
They shoot him!
Oh, he's gone.
Oh, wait.
No, never mind.
Oh, that's a lot of enemies.
Whoa, shit!
Okay, I did not expect that.
Alright, that's good.
Not me, though.
Not me.
As long as it's not me.
Alright.
Nice.
Alright, everything's okay.
Oh shit, that's a dead body.
Bro, you're tanking.
Finally, she's doing her job.
Is there anything back here?
I knew it.
Ah!
God, fucking, damn it.
God, damn, I hate it.
They're like fucking costumes.
Now I can't even trust dead bodies no more.
I can't trust nobody.
This is how you get trust issues.
Good, that's the way.
I mean, that's fine.
Oops, not that, though.
Okay, but...
Hey, wait.
No.
Where?
You know, brother, Seekran told me her kingdom housed a
great treasury filled with the spoils of her family's
conquests.
Perhaps this uncle was told some of that treasure.
Is that all she told you, Mamir?
Did she say where?
No, just that they kept it hidden.
All right.
What?
You can't do it here or here.
Oh, maybe I can, oh, okay, there you go.
That's right.
All on purpose, too.
I planned.
100% planned.
Okay, I have to raise this then.
I lower it.
Lower it?
I do.
Okay, if I lower it and then I go...
Where is that too low?
Huh.
Not too low.
I'm about to find out.
Oh.
Oh, there we go.
Wait, can I use this?
No.
Okay.
It should be enough, right?
Yeah.
Well done.
Thank you.
Which way?
they have can shed some light actually okay i was i thought
there was like extra reading up here all right yeah free
stuff oh breed what no she never mentioned what never
mentioned oh well it's not really what i wanted but okay oh
i have a heavy runic attack oh my god finally Okay, I can
upgrade it too.
Thank God.
Think how long it took when no one reads them.
Oh, please read as many as you can.
So the sword is on.
What the fuck?
Why was he so surprised?
It's just like, what?
A key to what?
Wonder what lock that key belongs to.
Oh my God, it's a side quest within a side quest.
Within a side quest.
end when does it end what do you mean I did all that it
never ends okay
this way I haven't even progressed the story yet I've been
stuck in a side quest of a side quest of a side quest oh my
God and What's the point?
I did all that.
What the fuck?
What is he doing here?
Oh my god.
Oopsie.
That's not fair.
Wait, that's not fair.
Oh no, fair guys.
Help me!
Oh my god, he just disappeared.
Oh my god.
Wait, that's not fair.
Oh my god, this is not fair.
He's not expecting this.
Oh, God.
I'm not okay.
I am not okay.
Okay.
I have the power of fire.
Oh, God.
Okay, it's okay.
Okay, it's fine.
Last one.
Okay.
what the fuck he just disappeared okay it's fine oh and
nobody dropped heels that's cool I didn't want heels anyway
what did those rooms say secret she loved another a king
named Helgi seems they were madly in love oh no wouldn't let
them marry oh come Amir you really didn't think you were her
first love did you i suppose i did guys this is a little
awkward but i thought i could be like pretend to be like oh
yeah but i might have forgot who she is um this i didn't
want to say anything at first but apparently she was an
important person in the story so um who was she again
who was who was her what was she oh the valkyrie queen wait
but i thought she was the valkyrie queen there was another
oh i never yeah i never met her i was just like they talk
about her like she was very important but like who was she
quest oh yeah pasto he was not was not up for that the
wolves have picked up another trail keep following their
heads oh prayer was the first queen oh okay that makes she
was the first queen and then so you're gonna replace her and
now i guess there's there's another valkyrie oh my gosh all
right wolves tell me where to go this way oh
I was secret when you saw last she's still incorporeal ever
since Kratos set her free of her corrupted form but she
hasn't let that stop her from helping any way she can hear
voices truth is I owe her more than I can repay I don't see
yeah when we freed her she could speak of little else but
her reverence for you seeing you yourself again would surely
be payment enough
But I do wonder though.
Oh my god.
Okay, guys.
I do not wait Does he follow me if I Like can they do they
follow me here or can I stay all they don't They're like oh
well Like no, he's at the edge my one weakness Alright,
that's fine That's good.
She's tanking.
There we go.
I did it.
Yeah!
Where's the others?
Oh, shit.
What the fuck?
Where did she...
It's alright.
What is he gonna do now?
I'm at the edge.
That's right.
What are you looking at, huh?
Ah, cheese.
My beloved.
They're like, oh no.
She's off.
She's on the other side of the border.
What can I do now?
Stop hitting yourself.
There you go.
I actually needed this too.
Oh my god, there's more.
That's fine.
Like what are they gonna do hitting me?
Oh shit.
Okay, it's fine.
I made it.
There, I can literally just stay there.
His arm is not that strong.
Oh my god, he fucking carried my axe.
You can do that?
Okay, that's fine.
She just dodged it.
How did she do that?
Alright.
All right, last guy.
All your friends are dead.
Boop.
Yeah.
Now I can open the loot box.
Is there any actual HP?
Okay.
At least I'm half HP again.
Oh, man.
If only all my fights are like that.
I have only...
Alright.
I was...
Poor things.
They can smell more danger.
They this way.
The horrors of our past can be inextricable from the
present.
You have to understand that.
Have I not been here already?
Wait, that's...
Wait, is that my...
Oh, he's here, too?
What the fuck?
Okay, it's this way.
Alright.
I figured it out.
This has to be the last place.
I must say, I think we make a good team.
With my brains, Kratos is drawn, and my lady's...
Wisdom.
Magic?
Yeah, how's he gonna say, magic?
For long periods of time?
I was going to say brutality.
That works.
What's over here?
Oh, yeah.
It was just a nice little hole.
It was a very pretty hole, though.
Very well carved.
Oh?
We need to work our way up.
This way.
I light that up.
For me?
Oh, there's two more.
What would the other two be?
Guess up top?
Yeah, oh, there it is.
Wait, how do I get over there?
Wait, but there's a chest over there.
How do I get over there?
Yeah?
I want to go there, though.
What the fuck?
How do I get over there?
I'm so confused.
use.
Can you cut away through the ice?
Oh, are the non-flaping magical ice walls now?
Oh, I see it.
I think the water just froze.
Right here.
Oh, there you go.
I see it.
A little stick.
Okay, now I need to find the last last pot.
I don't see any more pots, though.
Unless is all the way up there maybe gotta fucking climb
back up oh no it dropped down oh i have to drop oh my god i
have to do this all over again all right what would the last
pot be
i don't understand oh it's right here nice
drop down again.
I gotta grab my loot.
Alright.
Nice.
Yay!
Alright.
Loot required.
Alright, bye go.
Oop.
Go this way.
And then...
How do I freeze this?
Oh, this is how.
Or like, chop it, I guess.
I'm gonna say, I don't unfreeze it.
I mean, I have a fireblade.
I feel like I would use a fireblade instead.
But, I mean, that works, right?
Oh, fuck it.
Oh, no, I have to run to him!
No, I wasted all my fucking rage because I have to run to
him!
Oh, my God.
What a waste.
Let's hope there's no boss here.
That would be so awkward.
Alright, it would be very awkward if after this I have a
boss fight.
But...
Not that they have any idea.
That's what they're doing.
Oh, nice.
I actually need more heal.
Oh, I don't need more heals.
I'm actually full HP.
Ginger, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Boy.
Well, his son ditched him for a cool.
dad because he didn't because Kratos didn't buy him the new
iPhone and then Odin was like wow that's such a shitty dad I
would buy you that new iPhone and now my son ditched me and
valued possessions over thank you over honor just trying to
raise my son right I was just trying to raise my son
Boiled by fucked up.
He wanted, all he wanted was the newest aqua.
He didn't care.
And the flying sword.
Oh yeah, and the flying talking sword.
Okay.
I'll send that in.
Oh, shit.
all right get out of here you really think you can kill me
i'm literally the god of war what are you the god of exactly
god of dying embarrassingly maybe bam
all right i feel something it's stronger this time over here
all right we found finally found the fates okay you said
that but the last three spots we went to what makes this
different
oh no all right is there a tunnel this time it's ready god
if this is another dead end isn't it always the third place
you look oh i hear the voices they're calling me what do the
voices say hearing that creepy was i knew i wasn't crazy in
the mind it means we've stepped into their domain i knew it
i knew everyone also have have multiple voices in their
heads but assume nothing there's no telling what manner of
creature they've made unwitting god i knew i all right up we
go oh the voices are getting louder now huh all this loot
just hanging out there for free hmm a little bit suspicious
just a little sussy oh there it is I knew it things are
never free I fucking knew it nothing is free in life oh my
God I knew it I was like haha that would be so weird if he's
just standing here he's like are you done okay he doesn't
even care what the fuck is going on he can never deserve he
cannot change what is he doing oh he's just blocking I was
what is he trying to do oh he's blocking sorry i never see
that before in my life i know i do not know what block means
oh goodbye is that me he just stands there menacingly he
certainly seems real enough the traveler the parts in your
mind yeah what is this thing is what is this thing that he's
doing in front of me blocking what is that word what is that
new found technique solid thank you the super chat thank you
thank you listen to Doki's girlfriend cover to get her to
cover skater boy voices thank you the super chat thank you
thank you oh my god not another one oh whoops I missed oh
that's awkward it's fine Oh my god, he's trying to like...
Alright, there you go.
Heavy attack.
Oh my god, you're so fucking weak!
This place almost looks familiar.
But different.
Alright, nice.
I'm gonna save my rage in case there's...
I'm gonna try to save my rage.
I feel like there might be a boss fight soon.
So you're allowed to hear voices and talk about, but what I
do have to be put on meds and go to therapy Archer is
thinking of a super chat.
Thank you.
I think Kratos is already going through a lot right now
I think he's at the stage where he needs more than just
therapy and meds
What the fuck okay?
I don't know if you saw that, but he punched the cat.
Wait, she healed himself.
That's an ego.
All right, get out of here.
No more res is for you.
her and that cat.
They had history.
I literally saw her punch the cat.
She didn't even use magic.
I was just like, holy shit.
That's crazy.
I actually don't need to get close to them.
Get out of here.
Oh my god.
Freya's actually tanking for me for once.
I'm literally the DPS and she's the tank.
Alright, oh, actually over here.
How do I get there?
Alright, I want to get to that loot.
Alright, take for me!
Oh no, not the fucking magic.
Here we go.
Counselor to Kings.
Mary Wanderer of the Woods.
Robin of the Goodfellows.
Let me guess.
I'm a long-winded noot.
and i cannot change see you forgot smartest man alive
it's okay why didn't you even get close to oh me as well
what the what did you blow on me what did you spray on me
freya you're supposed to pull aggro what was that come on we
had an agreement here you just stood there What the fuck was
that?
I thought we had an agreement.
Toxic.
Hey, I got shot at.
She didn't do her job as being a tank.
At least we won't have to introduce ourselves.
Don't credit your reputation, Mimir.
They see the whole lives of any who approach them.
so gossipy though what is that hello what the is the set am
i am i hitting it oh shit okay i'm punching it i'm punching
it i got a little confused but i'm okay now okay i have to
wait i'm making just do it now
I'm trying my best.
There you go.
Wait, where did it go?
Oh, shit, this!
Okay, that makes sense.
I was like, what do I attack?
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, hit her.
Okay, nice.
Nice.
She's taking it?
I'm glad she's taking it for me.
I really appreciate it.
Oh my god.
I'm trying!
Wait, you're so far!
Wait, where did she go?
Okay, I missed.
We missed.
Oh, shit!
You're alright, brother.
Oh, nice.
There you go.
Okay, nice.
We gotta go to the shrine.
It's so far!
Is that like fair?
It was like 20 miles away.
Oh, finish it off, man!
Alright, nice.
Okay, this boss fight was easy.
They literally put the stride on the other side of the map.
Well, yet another gift of Fimblewinter, I suppose.
Yeah!
Okay, that was the easiest boss out of all of them.
Holy shit, he gave so much fucking loot.
Literally had like, like kindergarten attack pattern.
I guess you could say the phantom felt phantom pain.
But I'm...
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
This way.
Yeah, his entire body was just loot.
It was like a little pinata.
Pinata.
Oh, I'm going to keep that.
I don't need heals right now for once.
I'm actually...
I'm actually so healthy.
Okay.
Kratos does not need health insurance.
He's a man of health.
He's that healthy.
He's the symbol.
The symbol of fitness.
There's that itchy sound again.
Normally, I don't mind ladies whispering in my ear.
But this is positively arson.
Anyone ever tell you that you babble when you're terrified?
Terrified?
Ooh, it's pretty dark.
I'll have you know I'm the very most deeply apprehensive.
Making tension with humor is the sacred duty of a traveling
companion.
How very dare you, babbling.
Trying to distract himself from being from being a pussy
right now.
A door.
Oh, a door.
That looks official.
Where does this door lead me to?
I guess the phantom wasn't really a menace, but I'm...
Mr. Broken Bond!
Whoa!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Stop.
Why did you bring him here?
You are not welcome here.
Wait.
Vulture come back.
Oh, shit.
They're not real.
Freya, wake up.
He's dead.
Oh god,
there's so many oh my god
Holy shit, I'm so confused
It's only illusion, Freya, wake up
i'm glad you chain there oh my god i'm actually have to use
the rage
holy shaw oh oh my god you will not harm him
brother over here come get me i want none of this what hello
why do you have a body again secret brother hold off why did
you never turn on odin oh that's that's his first his
girlfriend oh hey nice oh no not nice
oh i'm not okay
remember it would be really helpful if you help out you know
It's true all of it, but for love of you.
I became a better man a counselor for peace and ally to all
those who
Maybe they'll be really helpful if you help out, you know,
you know, at least At least Freya actually shot him for me
Watch out.
Thank you.
Okay, which one?
Be rare which one?
Oh, no, that means I'm next Oh my god.
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
That's a cutscene.
I'll get my HP back.
It is
not her.
No, of course.
He can attack is in a tree.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my turn.
It's my turn for trauma.
Let's go.
Oh, fuck.
turn for trauma, guys.
I wonder if I just have to, like, survive long enough.
Nice.
Alright, nice.
But that's too damn bad!
It's part of your prophecy!
Nice.
all he had to do was buy him an apple oh no why won't you
get me my newest apple are you fucking kidding me i fucking
dodged that shit
oh i think i killed him too fast oh oh no it's over here oh
i to go inside the door.
Oh, brother!
Help me!
He's a murderer!
Oh!
He didn't guess we the newest off-board.
I think it's over.
Did we pass the test?
Did we do it?
Didn't feel much like succeeding.
I see the door has disappeared.
Or it was never there.
They toy with us still.
Is this what the door led to?
What is that?
Yay!
Psychological damage.
She must be theirs.
Will she take us to them?
I'll ask her.
Nice.
Horse!
Easy, girl.
Easy.
That's right.
Good.
Nice.
Am I allowed to be on top of this horse, too?
No.
Am I worthy enough to sit on the horse?
Whoa!
Behind her!
Oh, let's go.
Wait, how do I...
Oh, where's my prompt?
That's a good last.
Oh my god.
Temperamental by reputation.
In my land, they...
Yeah, those are the water horses, right?
They can run on water.
Of course, no Kelpie I know would do such a thing.
Unless it was disrespected.
It walks on water.
Yeah, that's what Kelpies are.
No mystical water steeds to speak of in Greece, brother.
There were the hippocamps.
They served the seaguard.
I battled one upon a titan.
Oh, yeah, the one that drowns people, yeah.
Yeah,
I know these horses from Frozen 2.
They're like little mermaid horses.
Oh, that's cool.
I love the little seaweed design for the tail.
Yeah.
You know, that scene in Frozen 2 where Elsa rode a water
horse and then like and it took her to like the heart of the
forest or whatever the fuck yeah i watched frozen too on the
plane not in the theater still i didn't give disney money
technically i watched it on the
plane like good kratos freya and mamir's head enter the home
of the normans tentatively Oh.
They have finally reached their destination.
I did it.
Isn't there supposed to be like three fakes?
I seek my son.
You know the child is an Asgard.
No, you seek.
What all who search for us seek.
the ending to your story oh i guess they're safe odin didn't
get to them the ghost of sparta furrows his brow menacingly
he resists the urge to grunt oh he fails god that is so
annoying like i seeking freedom from your scripts as if
knowing your lines would grant you the power god they're so
annoying they're so annoying the sisters of rage fading yeah
but you caught him the destroyer of fate there must be a way
to survive destiny is she making fun of us destiny park the
protagonists are speechless they do not understand there is
no grand design no script only the choices you make let your
choice are so predictable merely make us seem prescient when
my son was born shut up holy this is why they have no
friends and have to be isolated from society a needless
death and he did because you could not let him go because he
thirst this is why society doesn't want anything to do with
you you kill gods you're annoying but what kratos did was
not out of hate oh should i bring him a crown then he still
slays gods but now he's sad about it you are the sum of your
choices nothing more and because your choices never change
you will learn that heimdall intends to kill your son and
asgard what you will do what you do best well i didn't know
that the skies burn the curtains fall
again he misses the point yeah i'm like i you knew ham does
gonna kill him he's like i knew ham does gonna kill we are
leaving he
stomps away followed closely by freya i enjoyed your story
kratos pity it has to end so soon
So we came all the way here Just for them to be like I told
you so So we can't even do anything Really came all the way
here And then they're like We're like we told I told you so
There's nothing you can do You can't change the past Can't
change the future Oh I learned about Hamdell I did I did I
like how the The fates were like Um, then you find out, then
you learn that Hamda's about to kill your son.
And then I'm like, and then Kratos like, Hamda's about to
kill who now?
He's like, oh, wait, you didn't know that.
Well, guess you know now.
Yeah, technically they did give me, they did give me one
answer.
That's better.
I can feel things getting more normal.
He's like, oops, spoilers.
Wait.
That tree.
well isn't that interesting what is this yeah that's the
noose brother the one odin hanged himself with as part of
his endless mad quest for secrets of life and death and what
have you what are you doing it's a charged object
significant to odin perhaps i'll find a use for it that's
crazy the face where like he's gonna die and needless death
and then later on it's like um oh yeah sorry I forgot to
tell you because we told you that you're the one that caused
your son's death like that's fucked up Of course we bloody
won't the question is how that's fucked up.
They're like oops, sorry I guess I meant you were the one
that caused your son's death because you got super paranoid
after we told you that your son was going to die You know
Heimdall.
I grant you that he's a spiteful vicious.
I'm so loyal Odin entrusted him with Gala horn If we have
the chance to eliminate him before Ragnarok rock we
shouldn't hesitate considering his powers of foresight alone
that is an if of mountainous size all right we'll go this
way we never oh wait we did nevermind I thought I was
thinking about like it was her puzzle I forgot it was a
self-fulfilling prophecy I think it was a bitchy move for
them to tell her about the the prophecy this
is why society isolate that's why they don't have friends
your only friend is each other she did ask yeah and they had
a choice to not say anything even supposing we're all
perfectly comfortable plotting an assassination and I for
one am a might rusty at that measure yeah we've got no way
to reach hindal and no way to kill him if we did i have
killed god greater than him that's true i don't doubt that
brother but it's hardly my point but it wouldn't be funny
that is also true how do i get that
but he can't just do this to me
they're like oh it's gonna be scat sisters it's gonna be so
funny She doesn't know.
We're about to tell her that her son's about to die.
And oh my god, it's gonna be so fucking funny when she
doesn't even know that it's because of her.
Ha ha, wait until she finds out that she was the one that
causes his own son's death.
Kratos, I see something.
What do you see?
Oh.
Oh, shit, nice.
Fuck.
Have I been here?
I'm just like...
I mean, there's...
Yeah, but then there might be...
Oh, shit.
Wait, have I...
Oh, I've been here.
Oopsie.
Yeah, the ultimate prank.
It's this way.
Sorry, all the rocks blurred together.
better for me.
I think we're missing the no one's message here.
We've all got our tendencies and yours is to run headlong
into danger to protect the ones you love.
I do not intend to change.
Not about that.
Why should you?
Apparently my tendency is to kill the ones I love.
Yeah, like get punked.
I don't need you to come.
Oh, fuck this girl in particular.
Four out of 48.
It's gonna be a while.
No.
But Baldur's fate had many causes.
Prophecy among them.
How do you mean, brother?
There are many tales in my homeland of those who fulfilled
prophecy by attempting to avoid it.
So it was when Freya tried to protect Baldur, and so it was
when I accused my son of going to Asgard.
Then we agree.
It'd be foolish to go after Heimdall.
No.
If Heimdall must die for Atreus to live, then Heimdall must
die.
how can you say that knowing what you know because if
hindall is a threat to my son i must act it is your nature
well played i mean he is right because he has his son is his
future so like he's already lived through so much you know
he's already lived through so much pain and grief he must
he's like i want my son to go through the same thing like he
knows he's gonna die by killing Heimdell but like as long as
his son gets to live on his future live on his life and his
legacy that's all that matters to him yeah i can't really
blame a dad for that return home consider our plans because
like he doesn't want to lose his son like he lost his
daughter wait is he still where yeah he i mean technically
he's still wearing his like the red paint right i'm sure
there was some loose end we meant to circle back to give
your mind a little time to process everything he just
doesn't want to go through that again at the late i'm
certainly happy to spend time somewhere other than your god
it's your choice brother or is it the ashes i can't tell if
it's the red or the or the white the white paint yeah like
does he still have that on i can't tell if it's to snow or
like his skin uh i can't tell if he still has it on it's
snowing right now like the real reason kratos wants to kill
hymed up is because the game needs another boss fight but
now i think of the super chat thank you thank you all right
let's see if we oh armor do i need a stronger armor
Should we free the nipple?
Always free the nipple, guys.
That's where his power level is.
We can't restrict his power level.
Wait, can I level up any of this yet?
I disable it.
Why the fuck would I disable it?
Hold triangle while sprinting to activate.
Oh, wait, I like that.
Like, L1, R2 to quickly recall and perform a power weapon as
well.
I might as well upgrade all this.
And so I have enough XP.
Alright, just two more left.
Okay, I'll upgrade the blades.
I didn't check.
Norns have any good news for you?
No.
Ah.
Maybe buying something expensive to take your mind off it?
Always a joy to work on these.
Yay, retail therapy.
Yippee.
We love retail therapy.
Griffin, thank you for the raid.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
I hope you had a great stream.
Okay, can I upgrade anything else?
Nah.
What's the sword?
And for the Valkyrie Queen?
Nothing.
What about the nothing?
This increases the damage cost by extinguishing... Oh!
Hmm...
up my runic but my strength lowers though i like more damage
oh my god minus 36 luck
no it's fine i don't mind you standing around like that i'm
giving you money i just i just paid you what do you mean
it's fine god it's like it's like why are you doing lord
here and I'm like I like the money just got exchanged and
like leave stop loitering yeah have patience oh it does
decrease the luck by a lot whatever okay I'll craft this
it's higher which means it's better right that's how it goes
all right huh that might be the best piece yet today you
paid already business over
anything i talk about kratos yeah green arrow up equals good
all right nice take care of your armor and it'll take care
of you okay we need to equip oh my god i have so many new
runes I need to equip.
Was it a relic?
No.
It was...
Wait, do I have a heavy attack?
No, I don't.
Not yet.
Nah.
What was it?
There was like...
Oh, no.
Oh, wait, that's free.
Oh, there you go.
Amulet.
There you go.
Set a...
Increase...
Kratos melee damage.
Set an increase.
Wait, seal a...
Increase the damage of all death above.
Creases based on...
Ooh, wait.
Stun.
Wait, does it have...
Requires two?
I don't have two of the three of that.
Yeah, I remember...
I couldn't remember if it was the red or the white.
That was, like, the ash of his previous family.
Mack, thank you for the super chat.
Mark, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm so excited for the remaster.
I hope they keep the...
Don't they keep the the the sex quick dive
Yeah, Doki, what do you what?
It's educational The future It's educational guys It's the
birds and the bees Press circle.
Press circle to thrust.
Any move you make, you'll have seen it coming.
If you must face him, we need something else.
An edge.
You, Mamie?
Very well.
We will ask the dwarves.
Ah, the inevitable asking of the dwarves.
I mean, the dwarves know what's up.
Say the push away daughter, quick time.
have my priority straight slicer thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you what is it you want it has come to
my attention that nitho has been slain and as a result her
offspring have been let loose into the nine realms one of it
unfortunately without a proper role model to supervise i
even know he abandons his good spoil there i didn't know
there was a bad in your child quick at time event but
everyone knows about the bad one in order to avoid such a
great i'd like you to bring the lean worms to me i believe i
can act as a satisfactory paternal figure in their
upbringing you'll find the specimens gnawing on tears
throughout the realms oh okay this device to safely store
them oh did he lost the kids and i promise i'll you're a
terrible babysitter what the by yourself they're goddamn
orphans and you're already lost the kids extreme
personalities compared to wrestling with my emotions in the
most literal absences i dare say raising a handful of leaned
worms will be a walk in the park yeah but he doesn't know i
killed his mom though but like but like that's his fault for
losing the children
like literally that he was literally that's literally all he
had to do babysit and he couldn't even look after he can't
even babysit them um excuse me i killed one of the parents
the uh the other one just abandoned the kid so am i really
the bad guy like she was a single mother i didn't kill the
other one if she if her husband didn't abandon him and her
in the first place she wouldn't have got murdered by me i
have news who did the norns tell you how to get atreus back
do we have a plan the norns say atreus will be killed by
heimdall the plan is to kill heimdall first oh wow okay
heimdall let's see never lose loses sees everything coming
unpopular at parties this won't be yeah but he only sees
like what i my like sees like what was it what i think in my
head at the moment so i could just change my mind last
minute see and i got just the thing in mind to help you do
it either i'm head empty or just change my mind at the last
second yeah intent he only sees my intent what if i just
have no intent and despair even if we did drop near's no
weapon why would a oh you mean we combine it with that's
right and then when he it'll go english please brilliant
very well i suppose there's nothing to do but what go fetch
drop near
okay and how do i do that oh i need to talk to you again
instead of you guys continuing the
drop near i bloody knew these two had nicked it and odin
blamed me for it disappearing they stole drop near we didn't
steal nothing where the did he come from gifted what never
should have been gifted in the first place i will have
helped me kill honda never you mind all that it's a fucking
surprise we're artis but to even store drop near you need
you were saying What the fuck is this?
Is that a hot air balloon?
So now you intend to kill my dumb.
Violence cannot prevent violence, Kratos.
I truly thought you understood that.
God, what a fucking pussy.
How is he ever a god of war?
God, he must have got out from nepotism or some shit.
What do you mean, like war?
Yes!
Yes, like war!
Dear, fuck god of god are you you mean like war says the god
of war
man he's so fucking washed guys damn we're like god of
widening what is this
not my god of war
oh i'm gonna miss you little one Is that Daphne?
Daphne?
Or Daphne?
Oh!
Oh, it replicates...
Got it!
Yeah, I was gonna say, it replicates...
Rings.
Yeah.
It's the ring.
You're all worried about your son, but we need...
Heimdall's a threat, not only to Atreus, but to everyone.
He's Odin's left hand, and he carries the horn that begins
Ragged Rock.
If we have the chance to eliminate him, we should...
And it's just as likely a trap because the bastard knows
your intentions.
Never meet your idols, guys.
Here's an example of that.
...a finger on him.
Not one.
Well, I gathered what's fit for gathering.
How long will it take?
We'll have to go to Svartalfheim to get the rest of the
materials.
Not to mention we'll have to visit...
...the lady?
The lady?
Oh.
That's a relief.
Oh, he doesn't want to lick.
Ha ha ha ha!
Kratos?
Lick my ring.
My precious.
The lady?
No idea what he's on about.
Yeah, it's like that.
The lady.
I don't.
I don't like who I became on our last adventure.
I can't be around the violence.
God!
You're such a pussy, man.
What happened to you, bro?
Even now I'm retired and I'm still punching people.
I bet you can't even crush an egg.
God damn pussy.
Why do we even have him here?
He's just a leech, man.
He's just a mooch.
He's literally squatting at her home.
Might as well just throw him back in a prison.
See you out there.
He cooks.
He's not even cooking.
I bet he can't even stab someone.
Just a freeloader.
Hanging out in my home.
Eating my food.
I'll take it from here.
Oh no.
This whole thing were my idea.
I'll speak to the lady.
Ooh.
I never get to speak to the lady.
There are reasons for that.
Brock will go.
No, no, no.
I have to.
You heard him.
Quit your fretting.
I ain't gonna mess nothing up.
What the?
Huh?
No, you pimple shrimps.
Think that'll keep us out?
Well, think the fuck again.
what was all that then oh just sundry trying to hog all the
glory same old not that the gate what's wrong yeah what's
wrong with it most likely someone in neither valerian making
a fuckery of the works probably on account of all that
incursion and you got up to but don't worry you little
dangling head old brock came prepared i got ways in and out
from the old days don't look for on account of being stupid
we should just have brock we should just have brock kill
hymda he only has three out of four souls he could never
predict him at that point did you did you turn the door on
and off abandoned service tunnel direct to the forge bro at
this point so i can give brock the next brock and he's gone
you sure he was the right pick for this He speaks plain and
yet so colorfully I trust him his head ain't right, but I
trust him
Oh, I should not have taken that Okay, I need you to do this
so I can do this There we keep cooperating maybe someday
it'll be Asgard in flames that is not my goal Doesn't mean
it's not your destiny.
What are you insinuating, Highness?
Not a thing.
Alright.
Grab.
Can't spell Brock without bro, so true.
Why would he hide in here?
He feared something in these tunnels more than he feared
starving.
Oh, is this just bonus?
It hardly seems rational.
Fear seldom is.
Oh, it was.
Hey, bonus is it?
Yeah, it really is.
that was like not even like the initial place i supposed to
go so travel for liquor and explosives little on the nose
for dwarven culture isn't it ridiculing a culture you helped
undermine classic ace here oh all right might have found
that one okay let's just okay let's just stir that up oh
shit what the fuck okay i didn't think he was Towards me,
not gonna lie.
I thought he was looking at my tank.
Well, I can see why it's an abandoned service tunnel.
Yeah, there's some.
Oh, which one?
This?
No, that's just a...
That's just a barrel of wine.
He's fine.
Doesn't seem too bad.
Wait, do I?
Is that for...
Is that ice or flames?
Oh, I don't think anything matters.
Oops, that's my bad.
It's fine.
Okay.
Swing, swing, swing.
Is that ice or flame?
Yes.
Alright, that's bonus.
loot so all right light blue is for flames okay not a hotel
oil spill oh i should do that oil equals fire yeah
okay Nice.
What the fuck?
I did not use any shields for that.
You know what?
Fuck it.
I'm low HP too.
I might as well.
Slap dunk!
What the fuck?
Who's this guy?
Oh, there was a lot more people than I expected.
Oops.
My bad.
Okay, nice.
Okay, get out of here.
That's right.
Get yourself out of here.
Get out of here!
I thought monsters stronger than this.
You're nothing to me.
I don't even recognize you as real.
Oh, hey.
Well.
What?
Who said that?
Who called my name?
Wait, what are you doing here?
Rock!
How do I do this?
Whoops.
Let's just blow...
Oh.
I think I messed up the puzzle, guys.
Oh, that's awkward.
Wait.
I think I can fix it.
Um.
Oh, yeah, it's still doable.
What the fuck?
Alright, I give up.
Please listen.
You have to let me take Brock's place.
Why?
He can't talk to the lady.
Why not?
No.
Do not ask again.
Is it because he's three out of four?
Wait, explain.
I mean, he could give me more context.
It's not too hard.
It's not his fault, Atreus ran off, you know.
Or are you just being Brock's champion?
There is again.
You're insinuating and you know it.
Can't the smartest man alive put it together?
The giants conceal a mysterious figure who changes the fate
of Ragnarok.
Oh hey, what the fuck?
The one who's fought a war against gods and won.
I am not their champion.
I didn't even notice this.
We're each entitled to our opinion.
What the fuck?
Where there's a gear like that, there's usually a chain
somewhere.
Yeah, I was gonna say, what is this doing here?
The sigil arrows should work with ice as well.
What's that got to do with ice?
I don't see no ice anywhere.
Oh, hey.
Oh, extends the duration of ice.
Oh.
I see.
Oh, okay.
Oops, that's my bad.
I did not realize I was standing in a puddle of oil.
Alright.
How does this work?
These gates seem to be connected.
See if you can break that farm switch thing.
Ah, I see.
Oops, sorry.
Whoops, sorry.
I see.
I still see.
Oh, give me a sec.
That's awkward.
But I see it.
I see it, guys.
Wait, there's something here.
Yeah, seeing is a process.
Oh, whoops.
There you go.
I'm so smart.
Oh, shit!
That's fine.
Alright.
Wait, what the fuck is that?
What the fuck?
Okay, nice dodge.
Good job, Jokey.
Good dodge.
Okay, come on.
I dodged that.
Okay, nice.
Yeah, this guy needs to brush his teeth.
At least get...
Or at least get...
Get like a fucking air freshener.
Yeah, bear refment.
Alright, where do I go?
I need to get one of those gates open.
Think, Doki.
Think.
A puzzle to another puzzle?
That's fucked up.
There should be like a five-minute cooldown.
Ah, we've seen these troughs before, haven't we, brother?
Oh, we have!
Okay.
Now where'd it go?
Wait, where'd it go?
Oh!
That worked.
Shall we?
Wait, but how do I get here?
Wait, how would it go here?
Yeah?
Why water no go here?
Water.
Why you no go over there?
How do I get water to go there?
But there's so much loot here.
Oh, first go there?
Okay.
Okay, first goes there.
This opinion of yours, was that the reason you proposed this
alliance?
You expect me to lead your armies at Ragnarok.
That is Tears' job.
Not mine.
It's plain to see Tears know war god anymore.
Nor am I.
I have left that life behind.
Yeah, I've left that life behind, but look at me.
I'm still fucking badass as hell.
Forging this weapon?
Your choice.
You know where it might lead I am only protecting I know I
know and we both know the place is protecting your child
Can't use that excuse now I might I've retired but look at
me I'm still just as badass as I was before Outside of
retirement I get that
What the fuck?
Okay.
Cigil arrows won't work on this.
Then how do I do this?
Did it touch?
Cigil arrows won't work on this.
How touch?
Is it touching?
oh my god come on guys why no touch i'm trying to angle this
maybe a touch
Are you fucking kidding me?
How is that?
Oh my god.
Yay!
Simple geometry.
That's right.
What do you mean, VOD watches?
Non-believers, Star-Aze.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I can't believe it.
That's right.
What the fuck?
The scrimmer possessed by nightmares.
They'll be even more dangerous until we stun them.
Why do we stun?
Wait, what the fuck?
Oh, shit.
Wait, he's re-genning.
Wait, that's illegal.
Man.
Okay, nice.
I took him out.
I'm gonna say I was one stunned him.
I just beat the shit out of him until he's stunned question
mark
Just keep hitting him All
right, nice more HP There anything I have to do here
I'm about to go back here one day
Oh Above you watch out All right, it's fine.
He's gonna kill him first.
My god, Freya, your fist is not gonna do anything.
Like Freya, just use your magic!
You see this?
Okay, nice.
All right, last one.
What the fuck did I do?
All right, nice.
More heals.
Give me your loot.
Atreus' mother was a giant.
Isn't that right?
She was one of the Yodnar.
She was a giant woman.
Wow, what a woman she was.
I know not all giants are giants.
No, there's anything wrong with the disparity in size.
There's nothing wrong dating a giant woman.
Freya does not judge.
He's like, I will not judge.
That's what you're into.
Freya's just self-conscious because she's like, man.
Would he...
I don't know if I can live up to your ex.
I wasn't 20 feet tall like her.
Okay.
And she's right.
What do you mean?
You know what they say about multiple limbs.
Oh, there you go.
There.
Now we can open the other gate.
Yay!
Why is it you ask?
I was just thinking of how Odin antagonized the giants for
generations.
Nearly wiped them out of existence twice.
What do they say?
Now you may have a role to play in stopping him once in a
while.
You gotta watch The Little Mermaid.
do not presume to know not that little mermaid i'm not
saying anything you haven't thought her secrets haunt every
step of your path wasn't it maybe if you talked about your
doubts they wouldn't explode when you talk to your son i do
not doubt she knows what i left behind she would never have
asked out of me why would she need to ask she saw your fate
three of odin's kin dead because of the path she put you on
you don't think she knew exactly what it meant Sending you
to Jotunheim?
This is mere conjecture, and probably quite enough of it,
Highness.
We're all making an effort to cooperate here, after all.
Oh.
It's not for me to say.
All right.
Let's get that wheel turning.
Yeah.
I think it was the wrong time of her giving me...
Guys, what did she say?
I was using my entire...
all three brain cells trying to figure out how to do that.
It was actually, guys, I actually did not pay attention on
whatever the fuck the lore drop was.
I was trying to figure out the puzzle.
Guys, can anyone give me a quick spark note?
Let's try and figure out the puzzle, guys.
Holy shit, he has so much HP.
Freya, any moment now.
Oh my god.
Behind you!
He's coming!
That.
Nice.
She said dead.
There's no way my wife would not plan all of this.
She loves me!
Oh,
fucking hell.
Alright.
Shit, they're so tanky.
These guys are tanky as hell.
There's no way she would do that.
Well, who's ready for some fresh air after that?
Everyone.
Thought so.
It is close.
I can feel it.
She let me get a home run.
There's no way.
None of that meant anything to her.
Wait, what the fuck is that?
I'm going to touch it.
Oh.
Nice.
Always touch mysterious holes.
You might get something nice out of it.
There's no way.
There's no way she banged me because of ulterior motives.
She said she liked my eyes.
Banana, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Rao really wanted to create a spider side and use his dead
wife's last wish to say it was destiny for them to be
together in war.
Thank you for the super chat, banana.
Thank you, thank you.
We have a son together!
Does that not mean anything to her?
It just seems to me your thoughts...
Oh my gosh, she's fucking trying to gaslight me right now.
She's jealous.
She's nagging me.
And try to make me depend on her.
Both can be true.
When we get out of here, I'll give you some space.
Let you think carefully about whether you're ready for what
it means to make this weapon and to use it
all right this way
and it's working meanwhile i'll see what else i can learn
while we're here i'm very lonely for you oh hey there there
he is hey you made this bra i got everything all set here
Now we just gotta push on up to the forge.
Wait, where am I supposed to go?
Wait, why did she go this way?
Wait, why is she going this way?
She just flew away.
She's not gonna join us, Brock?
Why did she fly away?
I don't want to get ahead of ourselves, but could we just
come back to this one?
Oh, trust me.
why did she she just said why doki i wasn't listening to her
you know you know when when you disassociate a little bit
when they talk a little too long
she was literally she was literally trying to gaslight me
about my wife my dead wife might i add so like can you
really blame me for disassociating after she tried to say my
never loved me like she literally implied my dead wife never
loved me sorry my second dead wife
she never said that it was in her heart that's how i felt
when she said that my second dead wife used me and i was
like no no She implied it.
Wait, I've been here before.
Wait,
is she giving me space?
Because I refuse to listen to her and give her a new son?
Better take out that nest Oh, I got it.
Damn, that's fucked.
That's fucked.
I wish he'd do that.
These mutts?
No wonder they should.
You don't die when it came.
Bro, Brock, what the fuck?
I was so far away.
It's okay.
Brock, the tank is here.
Yeah!
That's fucking right.
I've been here before Because some of the chests are open
Some of the stuff around here has been open And I'm like
Don't remember ever being here before Well, I guess I was I
can't wait to meet the lady
Oh, this is where we broke tier out Okay, I remember now I
remember.
Well, come on in, stranger.
I never do get used to that trick.
Locals up ahead.
Oh.
Oh!
This is where the other humans live, right?
No, quit your nethering, you snake.
Wait, there are other dwarves.
With your protective gear.
And you've never seen a legend in the flesh before?
Wait, there are dwarves.
I thought they were like the you know the humans that lived
in that little pit Where are these boys doing here?
Think he understands us You see what's wrong here, don't
you?
Those creepy flying eyeballs made a nest up on the cable.
We gotta figure a way out there and clear them all It's bad.
I'll just keep hitting it.
There you go Destroyed a nightmare haunt to release the
lift.
Oh, I can't even use the lift yet oh
that was an asgard oh i thought i was an asgard i forgot
we're headed we're trying to get find a way to get to asgard
okay looks like that wheel up there opens the game not that
we can shoot or anything all right brooding that
oh no i don't remember everything oh no everything i learned
about puzzles this is it this is my character arc
okay i'm in svaldenheim okay i'm so svaldenheim Did you
notice the dwarves of the camp are twice as alarmed to see
block than they were to see you?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, because they thought he was dead.
Also because he's blue.
I almost forgot.
It's also because he's blue.
They're like, why the fuck is this dwarf blue?
Which is understandable.
I mean, why is he blue?
I can't think of it.
super chat thank you thank you track who needs hey i got the
crank cover you do the other stuff turn it copy that wait
why am i asking you to turn it look around find an angle
ain't this what you do find an angle oh this ah promising
supposed to do here though turn it again
that's supposed to do something
dokey think think dokey think think think once more
oh Okay.
Hey, I got the crank code.
You do the other stuff.
What?
Oh, this angle.
There you go.
All right, I found the angle.
There we go.
I did it, guys.
I thought.
I thought, guys.
Yay!
Replaced on both blades in the ground to spark, mash, or
more.
I have enough for...
Oh, that's a heavy attack.
Nice.
I only got the heavy attack for this, too.
I actually needed that.
I actually...
Let's see if we have any skills to upgrade.
All right, we unlocked everything.
Did I already upgrade all the level fours?
I guess I did.
Okay.
I think they see us who's there oh how's that who's there oh
fuck I didn't mean to do that I mean I think it looks pretty
cool actually I should just destroy that
okay that's not what I want to hit because they just die
automatically Yeah.
Now we can ride on up to the forge.
Come on.
The lady's waiting.
Hey, got another riddle for you.
Yeah?
What gets bigger, the more you take away from it.
Well, let's see.
Something abstract, I expect.
Appetite?
No, that doesn't work.
Well, what is it?
Oh, isn't that clever?
Bomb point.
What gets bigger, the more...
Oh!
hole yeah that's a classic that's a classic riddle
i'm so smart i knew that i definitely knew that all right
brock can just teleport himself to the other side it's fine
oh don't mind he's here think i'll grab some for the lady
grab some what the wind no you itch it the sound of the wind
how watch and learn What?
See?
Dwarven magic's all about the intangible.
Oh, I guess we're making the weapons.
He adds magic in there.
Stop what you can touch and what you can't.
It's about understanding.
Understanding what?
The nature of the things more important than the form of
the...
Oh my god, he grabbed the wind.
That's crazy.
That's fucking crazy.
Just grab the wind.
the win hang on I smell trouble oh I need to use my thing
took no damage through my fucking shield I get over here
that's fucking right That's right.
No shield to protect you now.
Bam!
So this lady then, the lady of the forge, oh, magical
creature.
Yeah, it's a crush.
Why, I've been waiting for my chance to meet her since I was
knee-high to Anoka.
But Sindri had never had it.
Said I was too uncouth.
but today's finally the day so pretty i love i love the
background for this the landscape i brought i've never seen
you so reverent are you nervous why shut up he's about to
leave me now a woman he's so nervous oh my god his palms are
sweating he's about to meal woman it's actually really
pretty though i love the background here the environment
here all right five out of 44 we're getting there guys we're
getting there
oh not just a woman but a lady i'm a lady it does not work
huh what is it this time huh out of the way let me look why
isn't it working do
i gotta fix everything in this dang city my own self i'm
gonna need a couple of things follow me what oh man why
would you be an arab boy that's disrespectful i tell you i
need that axe of ours to go kiss that material out yonder
the spiky silvery stuff You'll figure it out.
The what, Steph?
This lady, what does she do?
Well, we'll both see soon enough, won't we?
I know this, though.
If we're real lucky, she'll give us her blessing.
Doesn't give them to every piece, but the one she does,
there's something to behold.
The axe?
Well, that particular process was a whole nother cluster,
huh?
wait so what do i what am i supposed to do
what what's the spiky thing the rock behind me this rock
shiny rock this rock is shiny he said i'll know when i see
it but i don't know if i oh oh i know when i see it see he
was right and he was right i did it
all right here's the shiny rock Black.
Faye's the only one who ever got my highbrow sense of humor.
Damn fine woman she was.
Apart from her taste.
It's blue, just like him.
Maybe he's colorblind.
Now I need a chunk of that bronze material over by all that
busted up wood.
Oh, is this?
That's bronze.
Eh.
In those days, I get so caught up in trying to be the best
that I worked till I swum dropped.
Chop, chop, chop, chop.
You learn to keep your own pace.
Save your extra effort for when it's personal.
Like for when you finally get to show the lady who you are.
All right, here it is.
You sure didn't give up on that riddle in a hurry?
I give up nothing.
It gets bigger the more you take away, is it?
That's right.
Sorted, it's desire.
Nope.
What do you mean?
Oh my God, we're smarter than Mimir.
Memeer, Memeer.
Alright, it's not perfect.
But why is here your answer?
You won't get it out of me that easy.
Are you even a nerd, Memeer?
Memeer, you can't answer this very easy riddle that even I
saw.
One more crank to turn and it's onto the forge.
Like really?
You don't see the form of a forge, but we're going to the
nature of one.
The nature.
following him for the moment there
yeah that i solved the riddle all by myself without any help
because i'm that smart that's me
it's underwater where is the forge
oh here's she come that's the lady a mermaid she's also blue
what the fuck there's a mermaid
oh she's making the sword holy
shit what the fuck happened She just zapped it.
Smithing 101.
This is master forgery.
The blood of a god?
Holy shit.
She maxed out her forgery skills.
It's fucking insane.
She didn't even have to hammer it like the dwarves.
That's like...
That's like level one smithery.
That's the worst side.
Try Mountain?
And like, so what do I have to give in exchange?
I feel like there's no, there's always a catch.
There's no way she's giving this to me for free, right?
Oh, is that a new weapon?
Oh.
For free?
Just do it for the love of the game.
Oh my god.
That's sick as hell.
That's Ashley fucking sick as hell.
It would be an honor if you might.
For the love of the game.
Are you...
Hello?
Bye bye.
my job is done now she acts like i weren't even here
manmaids don't speak to our corporeal bodies i speak to a
part of our soul a part specifically you might be missing oh
so she doesn't recognize him as a person she doesn't she's
like you have no rights to speak to me
Fucked up!
Bro, why would you tell him that?
Why would you tell him that?
He didn't have to let him stay ignorant!
Yeah, well, the one to give us the blessing just fucked off
into the tomb.
Why didn't... Okay, why did Kratos not ask for a blessing?
It needs the blessing of a great blacksmith.
That's why she doesn't, he doesn't recognize him.
Yeah, I know he doesn't see it.
She doesn't see him.
But all that's...
don't have all my soul the blessing wouldn't mean squat it
is the nature of a thing that matters he's just too shy he's
like lady gave me spear what do i say that's sweet though
that thing that brock okay but like how the fuck does sentry
explain to him why he's blue if this is how he fucking finds
out with wisdom no I knew because century said it
let us return home he's like you just touched too much
silver bro that's why you're blue that's fuck though that's
fuck that the mermaid was like I don't recognize you as a as
he's like sure yeah she can't see him wink wink all right
there i got the spear all right how does this work oh what
the what the what am i doing
what the oh am i like duplicating the spear oh my god i am
what hell ain't this just like old time spear my like wait
wait wait wait so that if i add all of this and then what is
my right what is my r2 oh that is crazy oh now it tells me
what it does i'm gonna keep and then boom okay that's great
that's insane Okay, wait, wait.
I want to try it
I don't know what R2 does
That's fun though Okay, I should actually fight R2 hold R2.
Yeah, I was holding R2 Wait, wait, wait.
Oh shit.
I got to actually fight now Okay, wait, last one?
Where is he?
Okay, wait.
Alright.
What the fuck, wait?
What the fuck am I doing?
Is that what it is?
Ha!
I'm just trying to figure this out.
Oh, I'm blowing him away!
Oh!
I think this is the coolest way The blowing up one is cool I
like that move the most The drop near spears looking pretty
battle worthy to me Let's see if she can help us get out of
here too Alright
Finally I have a third weapon Up there see that weak spot
Jam one in Right there Oh, that's so cool.
Yep.
Guess we're doing this one, boy style.
Okay, Bragg.
I mean, he was a Spartan.
He was, I think, I think Kratos was, don't worry, Kratos is
very well versed in boy style as a fellow Spartan.
Maxim, uh, Maxi, thank you, this is for chat.
Thank you.
is if it's the first weapon in the series that's
specifically made for Kratos and I'll thrust it on him.
Look at the Super Chat.
Thank you.
But we got a little excited after he blessed the weapon.
That's why he didn't teleport.
A little bit of Greek wrestling.
You know?
He's used to it.
He's Greek.
Oh.
wait there's eyeball nests all over you just ruined all
right what's over there oh that's what's this is so broken
holy but i want to apparently that
oh oh my god the nest oh sorry i got i got too excited
better take out that nest or it'll be eyeball city Oh, God,
this is bad.
I gotta get a little bit of HP real quick.
Sorry, I got a little too distracted.
My bad.
Where's the last one?
Oh, there it is.
You throw that real fast.
Oh, my God.
Get out of here.
There you go.
that should be the last one hold r2 without holding our one
okay look trying to realize we're trying to figure out what
r2 does I
don't know if r2 is actually useful am I doing it wrong guys
what the fuck where do I go
see there you starting to recognize when there's a weak spot
Oh, upgrade?
Oh, okay.
Oh, that's what he's looking at.
I was like, no.
He was like, do you see the weak spot?
I'm like, I don't know what the fuck you're talking about,
bro.
Like, what the fuck are you talking about?
Why are we opening this?
all right nice yeah look oh all right gets bigger the more
you take away is it time because the more he's still trying
to figure out the riddle he's thinking too hard that's
bollocks now that i see it never mind today's all right
though my balls are taking over the ground we better beat
them out worry i got the pro okay nice i got the perfect
idea boom i'm just gonna kill him first
all right god i love the sphere wait the sphere is so
fucking fun it's so it feels so broken
for that thank you super chat thank you thank you new weapon
these new puzzles tread care for you get a decent angle and
fling a spear into it oh what do i do after that oh i'm
doing pull-ups now oh that's cool it's all about the proper
angle with those puppies you want it straight i'm telling
you you're too far to decide like that how the fuck is the
proper angle not seeing no weak down here but you keep
looking do i have to do it oh i have to do it here i gotta
be patient
holy i'm a gymnast oh my god no not the baby don't worry
i'll take you back to your your new guardian i'm gonna say
your mother but she's dead
Didn't mean to scare you or anything you did not right you
can bring that back to reticoster whenever you're ready You
don't if I forgot you don't have a mother because I killed
her
Yeah That's blocked wait can I open it again?
Oh, I can I thought the baby was the loot
All right, let's grab the actual loot.
All right, nice.
Oh, wait.
Sphere attachment.
We need that.
Nice.
Wait, that means I can upgrade.
Oh, my God.
There's so much stuff to upgrade.
Okay, I purchased that.
Wait, melee.
I feel like I use range more, though.
I'm going to focus on...
Uh, pull- oh there we go.
Oh!
Oh, we're gonna do this.
Okay, hold- hold triangle to slam the sphere.
Alright, so I can hold it now.
Move.
Oh, whoops, I have to fix this.
Wait, what?
Can't go through that yet.
Oh, there it is.
I was going to say.
Damn.
A bit late for butt.
Got one last favor to ask of the both of you, and we can
call a square.
What happened down there in the forge with the lady?
That's my story to tell, all right?
Agreed.
Well, for a period of time, perhaps.
you oh very well these ugly birds maybe those grim will take
him down those what nope who you think you are it's okay
he's focused on he's focused on Bach right now he doesn't
know I'm here okay wait what oh shit whoops that's awkward
All right, maybe I can't beat him up over him.
No, I can't.
I was going to say.
No, not him.
Behind you, big guy.
Wait, there's two?
Oh, this is bad.
Okay, wait.
Oh, shit.
Wait, it's not fair.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, I need to grab the heels here.
That's all right, Brock.
You do your thing.
I'm just going to grab heels real quick.
Oh, my God.
I got to grab heels real quick.
Yeah.
Fight that.
I didn't think I was going to have 20 other.
I thought it was just one guy.
Okay.
To be fair, I thought it was one guy.
I didn't think there were like 20 enemies that had to worry
about.
I'll see you back here.
There you go.
Fuck!
Why are you guys appearing to out?
Oh, this is bad.
They're getting closer.
All right, here you go.
That's fine.
Sorry, maybe I can beat him off cliff.
Okay, that's fine.
I can use this.
And I can use this.
And I'm on top of him!
And it's troll fight!
Troll fight!
And I can jump over to the other guy too after I kill him.
All right, all right, all right, it's fine, it's fine.
Still sun?
There we go.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, that's not what I wanted.
But that's okay.
That's okay.
And then...
There we go.
Kill the ogre.
There, see?
I figured it out.
And then with this, I'll just slowly...
Go over on the other side.
holy shit okay that's sick that is actually sick though
bro that the sphere against like the little guys is so
fucking strong the big guys maybe not so much the big guys i
just spam everything just spam all the combos Do I have a
new...
Oh, nice.
Nice.
I already have a new light attack, too.
In one of the upgrades, you can apply effects on your spears
to melee, like, poison, and fire more damage.
It's out.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, I like that.
Oh.
And then upgrade this.
I already equipped it, so I don't need to do anything to it.
Oh, what about armor?
Do I need new armor?
armor?
Ooh, I can technically.
Ooh, wait.
Ooh, but takes away my cooldown.
But I get more luck.
I like the cooldown more.
I'm just going to upgrade this.
Yeah.
I feel like that one's just more worth it.
Everything is just luck.
Is there anything else?
We're good.
I see how you'll be getting down From up here Uh Where's the
amulet I can add one more amulet
I don't know I'll put that in Actually Yeah Yeah we'll grab
This guy find my own way back Been too auspicious a date
Actually Can I upgrade any of this yet?
Yeah I can Oh Oh Hello to Suffin.
Oh, there it is.
The elements.
All right, there we go.
That's the upgrade we needed.
All right, yeah.
Okay.
I guess it has to be this, right?
Holy fuck.
Man, that's very convenient.
God, they left the rope here.
All right, let's go down.
And I'll give you those games working for you.
I only hope Sindri's in one piece by the time Brock's done
with him.
The ice beneath those two is thin enough under the best of
circumstances.
Yay!
Again, again.
Okay, this is where I'm supposed to go.
Oh, yeah, this is where I'm supposed to go.
All right, does Freya want to talk now?
Where is everyone?
Wait, yeah, where is all the dwarves?
Hello?
What?
Now a good time.
Oh!
I just want to talk.
Dad to dad.
Speaking of which, imagine my surprise when Atreus came
knocking at my door.
He's doing well, by the way.
And will continue to do so just as long as I return to
Asgard sometime soon.
What a coward.
Using a dwarf as like a meat shield.
Has a whole lot to live for.
Arguable.
Run along now.
Let behave yourself.
Run along now, little boy.
Never much cared for Brock.
But can't deny the dwarf's talent.
You came to speak.
Dad to dad.
Dad talk.
Do you, Kratos?
All that blood on your hands.
On your son's hands I want peace as much as you do Perhaps
we can find it together He's lying
That boy of ours Ours Is everything I expected Um excuse me
he came from my balls Not yours You sure he's yours Oh I am
very sure I remember the night he was conceived He is the
key your age to break free you did not do any of the work my
son is not your key oh god do they not have metaphor in your
homeland or rather did they biological dad versus stepdad
what you're doing right it's like steve fuck off steve
that's my son you may meet the god i once was
is that where he what do you even know of godhood in your
lifetimes has anyone ever worshipped you ever prayed to you
can you even imagine that kind of love no oh damn you don't
care about mortals you don't care about anything beyond
yourself that's not true but the Greeks conquered they
prayed for me you fear Yeah, the Spartans did.
Is it any wonder that your boy is in no rush to come back?
Yeah, he's projecting.
Damn.
Holy fuck, he's rage baiting.
You know, literally just came over to rage bait.
What about the dwarf?
Where he left the dwarf?
Showing up here.
At least you rattled him as much as he rattled you.
He literally teleported here to just a rage bait me and then
left his fucking meat shield.
Banana, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
There's a reason why Odin is selfish and not a team player.
There's only one eye.
No, it didn't.
It's crazy how, like, um, I thought it was funny.
It really felt like a dad versus stepdad situation.
Oh, shit.
Wait, what?
How did you...
Why did you bring...
Wait, why did you bring these people here?
Wait a minute.
Why did you bring them here?
Freya?
Yeah, no shit!
Oh my god!
It's alright.
I'm okay.
This is just a flesh...
Oh, fuck!
This is just a flesh wound.
All right.
There you go.
I'm mad.
Come on!
I missed that one time, but that doesn't matter.
There you go.
Jeez, they're so tanky.
Get juggled!
A drop near spear?
Holy shit, it took so much fucking damage, though.
Come on, I found a gate.
We just need to take the train down.
I do worry, though, if I'm being frank.
We've crafted a weapon to kill a god.
One could say you're on the verge of returning to form.
Does it scare you, aiding another violent god?
I'm scared for you, brother.
That spear could start a war.
It's time for a self-fulfilling prophecy!
Maybe the Giants had you in mind all along.
Time for another self-fulfilling prophecy.
Let's go!
Yeah, maybe if they...
Even though they are...
If they were right, I got cool-ass spear, though.
Look at that.
That's fucking right.
So what if they are right?
Look at this sick-ass spear.
Okay.
Yeah, it's worth it.
Starting a war?
Fuck it.
Let's go.
It is pretty cool.
Gonna start.
We are gonna start a war with my Shadamu Spear.
Let's let you go.
So this drop near spear.
You're prepared to use it?
To protect Atreus.
I am no one's champion but his.
Nor no one's god.
That may be my form.
It is not my nature thing is I know you guys want me to
shoot the crow but there's 48 of them And I don't think
that's possible There's just that's a little bit too many
crows and is let Odin watch the rest matters little there's
also the bit of news that Odin has some inkling of what
We're up to I thought I heard Ravens.
Oh, yeah, yeah, definitely.
Yeah, I left one of them out there some more lies What did
you expect you think he lies that Atreus is in Asgard?
On that, I'm afraid I believe him.
Then the rest matters little.
I saw a gateway near here, overlooking the bay.
We can get to it with your spear, I think.
Oh.
This way.
Yeah.
Oh.
Like gravestone, there's a keyhole.
Wait.
Be ready for combat.
What's this?
Oh!
That's right, for one now!
for what oh my gosh I did not expect a fucking a boss fight
though oh no this is he looks really hard guys oh my god
okay Jesus oh my god what there we go okay that might been a
mistake doing this.
Oh god.
Holy shit.
Oh man, I do not expect that.
I was like, oh, a tombstone.
I think I could do this.
I just gotta save my rage thing.
all right and i'll use this are you kidding me he can do
that
oh my god he got the purple hit nice
jesus i can't dodge that
Oh my god, that's actually so hard to dodge.
Holy shit, I'm just gonna do this for now.
Like, I have to get the timing right for the parry.
Fuck!
Like, I can't dodge that if I fuck it up.
There we go.
Okay.
Nice.
Fuck, okay.
There we go.
Okay.
Oh, fuck, guys.
No!
Dodge!
Because I hit...
I arm one before I jump.
I'm getting better though.
I R1 because I was spamming my R1.
Like I was playing Blood Boy.
Fuck.
That sucks.
Oh, that was such a waste.
I'm just gonna restart.
Restart.
Just kill me.
You mean four times the chive.
I lost too much HP there.
I fucked up the timing of the parry.
For the king!
Yeah, that king ain't fucking seeing you in.
Okay.
There you go.
Nice!
No!
Fuck!
There.
There you go.
Fuck, okay.
There you go, there you go.
Okay.
Just keep hitting him, hitting him, hitting him!
Keep hitting him, Bob!
There you go.
Fucking hell.
There we go.
Are you fucking kidding me now?
Yes, I am!
Oh.
I want to parry that.
I don't want to dodge it.
It's cooler like that, guys.
It's cooler when I hit the parries.
Yeah, I know Aachen, but like, it looks so much sicker,
doesn't it?
Does that not look sick?
You know it looks sick as fuck when I do that.
Okay, fuck.
He got me there.
what the fuck okay that's right you don't get that extra hit
though winning is pretty sick yeah but perry over it but
perry to get that window come on guys you know it ready
yourself for them there you go
fucking hell oh fuck okay there you
go okay
see I get sick triple perry when I hit those when I
for the king yeah you have for the king when you're fucking
fucking hell you got me there
what the fuck wait what happened there
okay I dodged There you go.
Alright, there you go.
Oh my god.
Please get me that.
Fuck!
Rage!
Oh, I took my heels away.
It's worth it, it's worth it.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Okay, I know I said like parrying is cooler, but then I'm
like Maybe you're right
Oh fuck Oh fuck what I couldn't even block it Oh hey that's
not a Perry.
You're right, guys.
Maybe a lava is more cool.
Oh, my God.
For the king.
Just use everything.
Use, oh, my God.
What the fuck?
Where am I?
No!
It's fine.
I still live.
Yeah.
Okay.
There you go.
Are you?
Okay, that's good.
That's fine.
All right.
I'm gonna, I'm just gonna grab this right now.
I don't think I'm winning this one though.
this knee.
What the fuck?
There you go.
That's good.
No!
Nice!
Okay.
There you go.
Oh, he did it!
You knew this was so bad.
Do me a favor, brother?
You see any more of these ghostly berserker tosses?
Oh my god!
You'll be doing the nine realms.
Alright, but the pairs were sick though.
Warriors wrong you at some point, Mamir.
Amulet.
You're quite agitated.
Even for you.
No need to rehash ancient history.
It's all the same to you.
Kneel before me.
Well, guess who was kneeling now?
Huh?
Maybe you should kneel towards me!
all right what's this massive ice wave that inflicts frost
damage and freeze enemy okay wait okay but that damage is
insane though i don't know i think this which is better chat
okay maybe one out of one
all right only seven tries let's fucking go i was thinking
of super chat thank you thank you um i hope you played a
master god series just so we can watch you fill the flaming
oh mini game just like real life i'm scared what do you mean
by that congrats for 400k in the cover thank you thank you
the super chat man thank you thank you i'm really happy that
everyone loved the cover you guys i'm glad thank you guys oh
oh shit what oh yeah Fuck yeah, let's do that.
Yeah, stream girlfriend.
Yeah, forward a king.
Maybe your king was a pretty ass.
If you can...
You died like that.
Like a pussy.
Damn, I can't believe the king had you.
Speak.
Need you to get something for me.
A hammer.
A weapon.
No.
A forge hammer.
Little thing.
Symbol of the old resistance.
Gield, solidarity, all that.
Or it used to be anyway, till the Aesir buried it under that
big, gaudy dwarf statue in the bay.
Might do the dwarves some good to see it again.
You're not worried that might draw the Inher Yara's
attention.
The old father nearly slit my throat just to get to you.
I might be past giving a shit what he thinks.
Just find me at the bar when you've got it.
Is this quest worth it?
bay with that spear i might be worth looking for darling is
he where is it worth it guys
is he worth it no all right goodbye i'm not here to help
your resistance do it yourself oh my god one i still have
hellheim i still ask god and i still yodaham all right let's
I just not like fast-traveled to here
now that you have a weapon to deal with Heimdall we just
need to find a way to get to him hi if that's still the plan
and you're a prop but freedom they can fight for their own
freedom guys the original plan to avoid I got my own
problems to worry about you know yes that's rather what
concerns me listen brother those things he said to you is
wood or nothing true though i expect retaliation is no empty
threat let's wait here the port is just gonna open up in
front of me anyway you're getting ahead of yourself let's
see if cindry has had any luck there we go i just realized
i'd never i don't even need to actually run i just have to
wait for the door to appear
Hey, ding, ding.
Does he want to talk to me?
You wish to speak with me?
I got one of your child.
One.
This one has a strong personality.
Good thing I've got experience with those.
Yeah, I figured out the meta.
Gives you something to do.
Get my zoomies out, you know?
There he is.
Think of the rope there.
See what we've done.
Now do the thing.
Boop.
Oh, look at that.
It's beautiful.
She's special that one.
Ain't gotta tell me.
Have you found a way to reach Asgard?
Um, not as such.
Oh, whoops.
Sorry.
Had a few ideas, but they didn't so much miss click work
brother without a way to ask god what are we doing i do not
know i need to think i'm good yeah all right retire all
right i guess i'll just make a new son does this too just
gonna retire smooth as snail shit like i said there's some
reason you expected it to flip sideways what no no of course
not i'm delighted to hear everything preceded as planned
well they did and it was a proper adventure no just give up
yeah i need to think give up you're making up words again i
said it was a motif and it was beautiful you are impossible
i'm the most possible one around here All right.
Epee time.
Why don't we just give him a new body?
How are you going, brother?
Sleep.
So we're just keeping blindly on then.
Hoping we don't walk headlong into Ragnarok.
Is that your plan?
Oh!
No more talk.
I mean, it works.
Like, what is he gonna do?
Open the door with his mouth?
Oh,
my dead wife sacks.
Oh, wife, I miss you.
Wife dead.
Ape sad.
Regret.
Think about wife.
Miss wife.
Sorry, this is a very emotional scene.
That's how I could think about.
Aww.
Oh my god, his chains.
He's so tired.
I love the background music.
Miss my wife, don't you?
Oh!
Wife?
Oh my god.
Wait, she's not a big, giant woman.
Wait, this is false advertising.
Think about wife.
Dream wife.
Miss wife.
Wife back.
Life good.
Well, your father seems very ready to go.
Shall we then?
we're we're reminiscing
oh there's artaeus but piece of shit son yeah but she could
be eight feet tall
after knowing how my son grows up maybe i should crash the
boat little one your father and i traverse this river often
one day you will learn to navigate its waters we live deep
in the wild woods the most beautiful forest in all of
Midgard and it is safe leave even in my dream I have to work
here game is plentiful and you will want for nothing
we're not far from the your father and i first met we nearly
took each other's heads off but he's softened since then
somewhat unfortunately for you he remains dreadfully stoic
i finally see my dead wife again and all i can do is I guess
because he knows it's a dream.
So there's no, like, reason.
I suppose it will fall to me to teach you language.
Your father can teach you to hunt.
He's not...
She's trying to, like, not be too invested in this.
Roll boat for a wife.
Have you nothing to say to your son?
What would you have me say, Faye?
Anything.
Let him learn your voice.
Let him know you.
Hmm.
He is far better off knowing as little as possible.
Knowledge is not always a burden.
Aww.
To think the mighty god of war frightened of his own child.
I do not fear our child, Rey.
for him oh yeah he doesn't know yet that he's gonna be a
magic user
we are not our failures we are not who we were we must be
better
huh Atreus is our future keep
him safe kratos does
she disappear our son wife bye
regret his wife why
does he never dream about his first wife huh
God, are you jolted away?
Because he killed her.
Oh, we're back to Arteus.
Arteus.
What did that wall ever do to you?
I'm building focus.
Something my father taught me.
Did it work?
Not yet.
So, what's your plan?
I'm focusing on anyway.
Mr. Broken Bond, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm doll keeps trying to make me lose my cool.
I can't give into it.
Next thing, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh yeah, that basically means that.
Training without me?
He begged his new wife while his old wife was technically on
him.
I mean, I think it's a great idea, but once you're- And his
daughter, dude.
remember that the dead the white paint is made out of his
daughter too her also anyways grandfather wants to see you
oh grandfather right okay here then take this and uh send my
regards to sif lady sif and treyus see you later and
through'd by through'd
not like not you though you're special oh the two of you i
swear
what's in the jar milk curd mom's favorite it says we have
Oh,
just one more piece.
All right.
Is there anything in here?
Anything new?
Hmm.
Nicely equipped.
What needs work?
Hmm.
I like my current bow.
All right.
Yeah, I'll
go.
Ooh.
Siphon Thor's room.
Everyone back home would freak if they knew I was in here.
Wait, what am I doing in here?
That's cute.
We're next to the...
We're next to the parents' home.
I think my bow is fully upgraded.
They don't know that.
They don't know I'm here.
Wait, they have no pillows.
damn they sleep like that that's a big bed bro do you not
know the size of thor oh i can use drop you don't understand
it's a lot more complicated than you think you don't need to
know why but i'm old enough this isn't about your age then
what is it about because by this point magni and modi were
set on the path that led to their death i don't understand
you never try to and help me why are you so intent to walk
the same path and with that boy no less she i'm pretty cute
that's why this is my dream haven't you ever you're not with
that boy we are asia we have duty not dreams and you need to
start acting like it sometimes i hate you damn that yeah
that seems a teenager and her mom.
Oh, yeah.
There's Hamdell here.
Oh, dinner hasn't been, or breakfast hasn't been served yet.
Yeah.
I hate your mom!
I wish I wasn't even born yet.
That literally sounds like that.
I just had to check something real quick.
I didn't ask people.
Maybe Odin's down in this library.
all right let's go down check the library look even though I
killed her brother like she even liked him anyway I can't
explain it to you but I can't understand I thought we were
bonding stop letting a wife think for you she's clouding
whatever's left of your brain this isn't about no it's about
your limitations Now go smash something, will ya?
Honestly, I like you better as a drunk...
Damn!
That's fucked!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, he's so sad now!
Dad's just dead!
Oh my god.
The cycle of abuse continues.
Yeah, Thor definitely did not stop.
He continued the cycle.
What a great role model.
Father of the Year.
This is where you killed Amir.
Isn't it?
Generational trauma.
Tell me.
Can you murder a landslide?
Smother a storm.
It was more a force of nature, a vessel of power.
I was young, foolish.
saw an opportunity to create something more I know you think
it's cruel but I did what I had to to protect my own recall
your son better when he was drugged I build your house here
what's in there I'm gonna trust you I'm trying to tell you
in the wake of Amir's death I saw something the rift
possibly the birth place of reality.
I looked inside and something was there looking back at me.
It whispered to me, things I couldn't possibly comprehend,
but I knew they were true.
When it blinded me, I thought it was over that I'd never see
inside again.
And then I found this.
And I knew that it would finally let me see the answers.
You see, son, I'm going to go back I don't know where I go
when I go.
There's no Valhalla for me.
Ragnarok cannot be the end.
I need to know there's something more than this.
I need to know what happens to me.
No, he's fucking going crazy.
Trying to figure out the answer.
That's the truth.
The writing on here.
Talks about a cold breath.
breath wind it's got to be hellheim hellheim you say i'll
take it
and i know just the person to accompany you is it my new
girlfriend
yeah i'm trusting you my old girlfriend is to show up
because that'd be awkward you can count on us oh my god a
bonding trip with my new girlfriend Oh, uh, forgot to
mention.
Heimdall will be joining you.
What a privilege.
For all of us.
Oh.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Hold up.
You don't want to walk into the blistering cold of Hellheim.
Without this, have free life.
It should keep you nice and toasty.
You're welcome.
Hell yeah, Hamda.
The mere city of an Odin couldn't survive the cold in
Hellheim.
You believe everything that old goat's Oh, not a chaperone.
Nah, we're going to make the most of this.
I have two, so does that mean that there's two people that's
going to help me in fights?
Or is time just going to watch?
I have something else to do for the Allfather.
If you run into any trouble, just scream so I know where to
find your bodies.
Bro, better be a wingman, not be super lame.
let's grab some money equip the mask okay there you go i
forgot how to use this finally i can test my skills
alongside the real valkyrie expert first off hellwalkers are
nothing compared to valkyries second i thought you didn't
believe me
it has to be here somewhere there has to be a dead end
somewhere near here oh my god that's great it's just you and
me with no chaperones
Say, how does she...
What the fuck?
That's fine.
She can help me do everything.
Yay!
Of course she's cracked.
That's my future wife.
For the record, I believe you're right.
fought the Valkyries.
I just don't believe it was grandfather who corrupted them.
Or that he caused the desolation of Midgard.
Or that he had all the giants killed.
Am I missing anything?
Yeah.
Lots, actually.
Yeah, my grandpa... There's no way my grandpa did all that.
He was nice to me.
Oh, man.
She's definitely sheltered as hell.
What's that word?
I got this.
I'm just supposed to watch.
I can't watch I mean I'll watch look at her go Wow she's
really good but she left wait why is he wait I thought you
were gonna help I gotta say she's like yeah she's absolutely
sheltered how did she how did it get to me I thought you
said you got this well what other heinous crimes is He
decimated Vanaheim, tortured Tear, murdered Groa, murdered
Amir.
It goes on and on.
And where'd you hear all this?
Freya and Amir told me.
Oh, so his traitorous ex-wife and a bitter former advisor.
Got it.
Look, you don't believe me.
She is so sheltered.
Either you're full of crap or you're a hypocrite for helping
him.
Can we just focus on the mission?
Damn.
Yeah, no, she definitely never left Asgard.
always the person here is now but he changed maybe odin can
too i know how hard it is to hear this stuff but you should
know the truth what you choose to do with it that's up to
you
like okay okay yeah so what if my grandpa did do all that
you took it you accepted his sword why are you helping him
It's true.
Those are good points that she's making.
This is where the masks had to go.
Yeah.
We'll find a way around.
There's some way.
There's some.
Do something here.
Oh.
Oh, there they go.
They made me a little hug.
We're out of walkers.
That means we're headed the right way.
My grandpa potentially could be a murderer.
But like, he was good to me.
Oh my gosh, that should...
There we go.
Nice.
Yeah, no connection there.
Oh, there's more stuff people here.
Oh, what the fuck?
There's more over here.
I mean, I could just do this.
Deer time!
Yay!
And just...
What?
Uh-oh.
Okay, I'll take these guys away.
Alright, that should be all of them.
Alright.
Can I go up here now?
there's a big hole up there now i got your way around they
are like quiet yeah yeah i definitely got this oh hey we're
okay right i guess maybe our families are just meant to be
enemies oh it's like romeo and juliet that's so romantic
what i do believe is that you'll make a great valkyrie i'll
tell your mom the same thing even if she scares the life out
of me
Now, we have a mask piece to find.
Alright, wait, what's this?
Falling sky.
Nah, my other one is better.
I like the damage more.
Damage means they die faster.
And I like that.
Why stun them when I can just kill them faster?
Now what?
Not sure.
What?
Well, my gut's telling me what we need is here.
Oh, I'm stupid.
I forgot it's R2.
Sorry.
I forgot his idea.
I was like, why isn't it working?
Just being a little silly.
Getting one's easy.
Getting good at shooting is the hard part.
Maybe you can show me.
I'll be the first Valkyrie Archer.
Shit.
Could be our way up.
Let's head back down and find out.
Alright, push time.
Okay, pull time?
oh no jump time we go right let's do this first nice you
know what dear time oh no she's just running away she just
ran away
oh my gosh she's just beating up an old lady what the fuck i
think i'm in love
oh my god guys i think i'm in love she beat up an old lady
for me there has to be another way keep your eyes peeled is
there anything in here
no all right so romantic Atlantic.
What's the mask say?
So the mask's pull is a little weird with all these
buildings in a way, but I think we're going the right way.
You think?
All right.
Another chest.
I'll go this way.
Hello?
Anybody?
Oh!
Sorry, I got this.
God, that is so strong.
I love that.
move let's take too long to like charge to charge the
cooldown all right my tank is up oh my god my tank is so
strong my tank girlfriend just in time for Valentine's Day
sure sure are you messing with me I need this to go well.
I need my family to see there's only one way we both do
I don't say I need to equip the mask when there's literally
only one way in my path Mass All right, here it looks like
it's through here Let me get that for you.
Oh, she's so strong.
Hope she uh friday carries me see anything in there I see a
very beautiful woman damn okay nice whatever you shot
crashed through the floor again let's head back and check it
out so I talk about my mom a lot what's your dad like he's
intense like he's trying to force me into this mold but I'm
not sure that's me oof well I know exactly what that's like
thing is I don't I don't know what I want.
Dev.
That's right.
Get shit on.
Get predicted.
Wait.
Get the beast out!
That's fucking right!
Yeah, that's not a deal breaker, right?
Oh shit, what the fuck?
That's not, that's not a deal breaker, right?
If I can turn into a wolf?
That's pretty cool, right?
cool yeah i think she liked it guys i think she liked it
when i let the wolf out
actually i'll use this holy that was strong the rush does it
ever go away yeah chicks dig the wolf mom's gonna have a
real tough time keeping me in asgard after this guys it's
working I'm in I'm so in you know what happens after the
adrenaline rush guys
let me see if I can get upgrades too I knew it I knew I had
upgrades archery just gonna upgrade some archery stuff the
mask showed it was straight ahead earlier of course the
waste blocked maybe they're trying to keep people out or
something in I bet there's another way around there always
is all right think Arceus think think think she said there
has to be another way in okay me back home back here
anything around me
Matt says to go here no oh there it is I didn't see that oh
my god that was so well hidden to be about three I didn't
always after a bad fight with mom I snuck out and found them
training somehow bad girl such purpose like they knew
exactly where they needed to be I have a feeling she's gonna
swap size isn't she she gonna find about how um looks like
it's through here how like her grandpa is actually a really
horrible person in the end too heavy shut up i'll take a
look but i want to hear the rest deal have
you seen these arms there you go not bad i know
that she's in love with me and then she's gonna swap sides
no apologies it gave me clarity for the first time i saw my
path forward clear as day she was born for this
two bad giants have to follow prophecy who cares make your
own path just like we've been doing here oh that's so
romantic she's like who cares what fate tells you you.
Be your own person.
Oh my god, I'm so in love.
No, let's see.
And then she's gonna die.
I think she's gonna like, she's gonna like, um, what do I
do?
You join my side and then she's gonna die.
I'm like, no!
My love!
Stop aside, little man.
And then his first love dead.
Well, his second love, technically.
Got it.
Sure looks like it.
All you.
Definitely.
Oh, my God.
I'm already such a good boyfriend.
Look at that.
I lied to her.
Built your relationship off lies.
Artea, it's good for you.
Just like your dad.
Oh, she's like, did you see that?
Did you see that, guys?
It was really cool, honey.
Man, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Not bad.
Guess you make a good team.
Oh my god.
I think that's first base.
What's that?
Oh.
There's like a thing here.
So that means I have to...
There's something I have to do for that.
I hope I'm not trying too hard.
You think I seem too desperate, guys?
Or is that just the right level of desperateness?
It's like here.
Looks like it's through here.
But it's blocked.
Huh.
What if I...
Yeah, I was gonna sit.
Aha!
Can you get up there?
Yeah, I don't want to see my We see my jumps?
See if you can find a way to cut the crate down on the other
side.
Hey girl, watch this.
I do a leg game.
That's right.
Bam!
And arm game too.
See that girl?
There's more of that.
Where I come from.
A bit too desperate.
Hey, what's over here?
Was I too rude about her grandfather?
She should know the truth right Come sadly, oh, hey, you
talking to me, uh, no just talking to Ingrid
Wait three spectral rules wait that's better than oh, yeah,
the wolves are bad more damage Three is better than one
Oh my gosh, she's so supportive.
I'm so oh, oh, hey, what's going on out there?
Everything's fine!
No more, I got this!
What's she gonna do?
Disappear?
Nope.
But I can summon the three wolves.
The wolves!
Oh my god, okay.
It's not overkill, guys.
Holy shit, that's a lot of wolves.
Oh shit.
Oh my god.
I'm not the frost.
I'm just gonna shoot this real quick.
What the fuck?
There you go.
Jesus Christ, he takes forever!
That's it!
That's how I'm swinging my!
I'm swinging my bow!
Okay, this is actually a lot faster.
I'm like, I give up.
Roof force.
What is the power of brute force?
Oh, thank you for the rain.
Thank you.
Oh, yeah, a good stream.
All right, the path's open.
Let's go.
The mask is freaking out.
Rose are meant for a minute.
I'm like, what mask?
Trying to pull it out.
Ingrid, end game.
Ladies, ladies, please.
there's plenty of Arteus to go around I am a giant after all
you know what they say about Giants you see we got to get
out of here the mask we're so close besides I don't think
it's dangerous are we looking at the same thing Maybe he's
locked up for a good reason.
Oh, that's a giant wolf.
It's a giant thing.
Look, he just wants to be free.
The piece must be behind him.
Trust me.
Alright, let's start with the lock not near its teeth.
That's a big ass wolf.
Why did it lock you up?
Aww.
Poor doggy.
Don't worry, I'll free you.
Let's free the giant wolf.
really good things to have surely he'll appreciate me
freeing him and then he won't fucking eat me yay heavy
sleeper let's do the next
which giant wolf is this there's so many wolves in norse
mythology i've lost track
who let the dogs out i did
there oh my god we got clipped his nails that's not good
looks like there was another one under his foot holy fuck oh
no he has a skin rash oh poor guy oh shit okay goodbye
you're welcome look in the chamber okay it's just like I'll
do it myself.
I took you too long.
No, he's just blind.
I'm pretty sure he's very much alive.
Dead end?
Please tell me it's down in the water or something.
There's...
Yeah, he was like, you took too long.
This has never happened.
You said trust you.
And we let that thing loose.
Grandfather's gonna kill me.
We gotta get out of here.
Come on.
Oh.
The mask is in the wolf.
through wait up maybe we missed it oh my god it's it's gonna
be okay the mask is in the whoa oh my god did he do that oh
shit i made a mistake i'll fix it oh don't worry he has to
poop right that's usually how it works we just have to have
him poop it out how the where the where the fuck where the
fuck did he go you absolute unqualified You know that thing
tears holes between realms, right?
Oh, that's not good.
I mean, you were supposed to chaperon us.
You failed your job.
Half-breed!
There's no way you're pure blood, bro.
There's no way you're 100% inbred.
That's just calling yourself inbred, stupid.
to think that you were ready you helped him didn't you what
side are you on anyway copy oh try me and find out oh and
what are you going to do exactly oh You see, everyone takes
it easy on you because they are afraid of your father.
I am not.
That fat, drunken, utter piece of trash.
Holy shit, he's so good at rage baiting.
Again.
Yes, yes, the dumb does not fall far from the tree.
Very well, then.
Give me your best shot.
Oh, shit!
You have a lot to learn, little girl.
Starting with who your family is and who it is not.
Just waiting till I'm a Valkyrie.
Oh.
You really believed the Allfather would allow that to
happen.
Oh.
He doesn't mean that.
that do not let this little weasel feed your delusions any
longer enough
so close stop he just wants to make you mad yeah well it
worked yeah that's so hot she's so hot guys you toddlers are
boring if you are finished throwing your little tantrum we
should go now because i cannot wait to watch you explain
this message successful rage bait he won
bros rage baiting teens for no reason that's enough reason
guys that that's enough reason Did you not see what he was
able to do?
And you?
Loki of the Yotnard.
It keeps me up at night.
Bro has a blue checkmarking earning money from Twitter right
now.
Shades of your shortcomings almost.
Yeah, he probably has Twitter blue.
If we could only somehow harness your uselessness, we could
fuel this entire city.
Fine.
It's all on me.
Just leave her out of it.
I don't need your help, Loki.
Sorry.
Save her for the all-father
Oh my god.
That's yeah, he doesn't even that's true.
He doesn't even have Twitter blue.
He does it for the love of the game
We have a lot to discuss.
Loki, I'll meet you.
Yeah, he was a bad chaperone.
He was a bad babysitter Okay, yeah He went quite well Wait,
what?
Wait, he had another mission?
The mask, on the other hand?
Well, they are merely children.
I mean, that is true.
He's not wrong.
Like, that is true.
Like, what's wrong with that?
It's not even an insult.
I am a kid.
Thanks a lot.
Throod, I...
I don't want to hear it.
Everything was fine until you showed up.
I'll make it up to you.
I swear.
I didn't mean to.
How was I supposed to know the mask was in the wolf?
I didn't know that.
Who could have known?
Our first fight, guys.
It's just our first fight.
My little girl.
You can't keep undermining me like that.
Aw.
She's gonna do what she wants.
Wouldn't you rather I at least help?
Know where she's going.
Keep her safe.
No, I'd rather us be a team.
I'd like you to back me up for once.
You're ruining what little relationship I have left with
her.
I'm doing the best I can to keep this family together.
Oh.
If that were true, you'd stand up to your father for once in
your life.
Oh!
You're right.
Honey.
No.
You're right.
Oh, shit.
What kind of example am I setting?
Seems the only thing I can do right these days is destroy
everything around me.
Holy fuck.
This entire family is fucked.
We need you here.
I need you.
I can't do this by myself.
Yeah, she's needed dad.
Not a cool dad.
Well, this felt too real, guys.
That felt...
He needs to break the cycle.
Thor needs to break the cycle.
That felt way too real.
Bro, someone...
Someone was writing from their hearts right there.
I really messed up.
It's times like this, I really miss home.
Oh, I can eavesdrop on Odin?
Well, too late.
Before you came here?
Someone who took care of you?
yeah that was really good maybe I could help you find them
without you know just screwing it up sound like a plan
someone knocked on the door hello Odin I come in I heard
what Heimdall had to say I'd like to hear it from you what
happened It wasn't there.
I was wrong.
Well, we all make mistakes, son.
But freeing Garm, that was a big one.
Chaos is already spilling out into the other realms.
We're safe here in Asgard, but everywhere else.
I think I want to go home now.
I fucked up.
I just want to go home.
Run away from responsibility.
My dad's not that bad.
He's like, I think I wish my dad.
It's not that I don't trust you, you understand.
It's the company you keep.
Oh, and Ingrid?
Ingrid?
No!
You want to stay with me?
My sword, girlfriend.
When you do decide you're ready to continue our work here,
Hogan will be waiting for you in your old home.
You screwed up.
Doesn't change the fact that you're welcome here.
oh and say hi to my mirror for me
he's like if you want to keep your gifts you have to come
back home that's so fucked that's so fucked i can't believe
it waiting a while oh my god 3000 xp let's fucking go i'm
like no longer sad
sadness gone he took away my he only used your iPhone when
you're at home
after launching an enemy into the air
I don't know I mean I'll do that but I think I'm gonna keep
I'm gonna see if there's anything else I can upgrade
yeah I'm gonna save that then
oh shit of course I'm gonna see.
Oops, wrong.
I mean, that's fine.
Are you still alive?
Oh shit.
Oh, what the fuck?
Where did he come from?
Better use the Mystic Gateway quick.
Yeah, there's the Mystic Gateway.
Freeing arm.
How did I screw up so badly?
Okay, wrong home again.
You had to Fresh and cured.
Yay!
He got XP.
I guess it's time to face him.
Oh, is he gonna show up from this door again?
No.
Almost home.
It's gonna be fine.
Alright, we wait.
There you go.
Can't believe I ran.
Wait, what?
It's you!
What the fuck happened?
Everything seemed fine earlier.
Yeah, I know.
I was like, what the fuck happened?
I'm trying.
Alright, nice.
Get kicked!
I'm not gonna lie, my melee is so strong.
Oh shit, I didn't even see him.
That's fucking right!
I need more power!
A spell?
I'll show you how.
Lassarifa.
Oh.
That's a refund.
Oh, shit!
I didn't know I was supposed to spam it.
Oh, and the dad's gonna save my life.
What?
Ingrid?
Oh, dad!
Sorry, I thought about my girlfriend first.
Oh, yeah!
Oh, what?
Oh!
I don't know if I like that.
I like the Spartan Furry more.
I feel like...
No, I still like...
Yeah, I definitely like the Insta Kill.
Which one's better actually?
Insta Furry or...
It's OP against bosses?
Oh, okay.
That'll use it for bosses then.
Oh, fuck.
Alright, it's fine.
Oh my god, please just...
You're saying two words!
You can say it faster!
Alright, that's how you get to Nidus.
Is it over?
God, you're so used.
Yeah.
so useless where is atreus atreus has the runaway returned
and brought all this with him
okay atreus
wait where is he just hold still i told you i'm fine you're
bleeding quit your blubbering is it over boy where did the
boy go i just saw him boy oh there you are you're grounded
mister
oh oh shun oh he's crying oh my god he has emotions oh oh
that's sweet that's actually sweet Aww.
Atreus.
Aww.
It's all my fault.
It's not tears.
I'm just sweating.
They're everywhere.
That is not your fault.
Yes, it is.
Oh, that's why they were here.
It's because of the claw marks.
That's why they spawned here.
And I set him free.
I thought that if...
God!
you feed garm garm who feed garm that's madness surely not
you young one if the hound of hell is loose he'll chew
through the fabric of the realms hellwalkers are just the
beginning what were you thinking i know i fucked up there
was a girl and and like there was there was a girl and like
i really wanted to impress her
that was that was method acting guys yeah damn you don't
mind i'd rather stay i've had my fill of visits to hell home
she was so pretty and i thought i thought she would like me
back if i was breed the dog.
And I thought she'd think I was like...
And now she thinks I'm super late.
Boy,
fumbled again.
Don't you would not survive high school as a boy.
Yeah.
This is of the utmost urgency.
Oh?
Where is it?
The roleplay's getting a little too real.
Give me a sec.
I'm getting loot.
Holy shit.
I can chill.
What is better?
Wait, what was the other one?
It was Furia.
Which is better?
Rath or?
Fury, guys.
I hate Valor.
Which is better, chat.
Fury.
I do like the life steal, honestly.
I like the life steal a lot more.
Alright, where the fuck is this squirrel?
I apologize for my brusque tone, but whatever has lately
transpired in Helheim is completely unacceptable.
I must insist you remedy the situation without... Alright,
fine garb.
Okay.
Helheim, post-haste, and undo whatever it is you've done.
Alright, before we do that, I gotta grab water.
I'll be right back, guys.
And, might I add, never do it again.
And if you must imperil the fabric of reality in the future,
please do the courtesy of notifying me.
In advance, if at all possible.
I'm back.
Uh, Nexi.
Oh, wait, wait a minute.
Nexi, Medi.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Ginger, thank you for the super chat.
Bringing a giant reality and ripping wolf from hell feels
like a bit too much as a metaphor for purity.
All right, here we go.
Got my water.
Damn.
All right.
Aren't you gonna, you know, reprimand me?
No.
We wait here.
I am.
silence you are safe as long as you're a safe boy maybe i
should run away more often atreus kidding sorry atreus you
just came back no more jokes made it from drop near what's
that uh ring but what's its story i do not know you were not
there to ask
yay magic door is here Yeah, his question privileges are
over.
Oh hey, there's the raven.
Yeah, he has no rights to ask.
No rights to ask questions right now.
A desperate creature can be the most dangerous.
Not until we...
Not until I feel better.
And you cool down, and then he can ask his questions.
how far are we right now i feel like i i don't even know
what no why are you not working with him it's not what you
think whatever he promised he cannot be trusted i don't know
we cannot be 50 now i was i thought i was 50 starting the
game no you no no no that's a die.
I refuse to believe I'm 50% now.
There is no way.
All right.
Wait, do I not have my fucking son to help me?
Like, where is my son?
Oh my god, I got two times.
Okay.
All right.
thank god okay okay i was gonna say i i was trying to look
at chat try to figure out what percentage i was at oh now
he's here okay all right now he's here to help thanks boy
i was like wondering where the fuck was he
god fuck it
He thought could solo it.
Alright, guys, so what percentage are we at?
This ice is in the way.
I will handle it.
The wind from your wings.
I can finally read!
Wait, what the fuck was...
Okay, was I just pretending not knowing how to read and it
was forced ahead to read for me?
Wait.
Wait, did I not need him to read for me?
And I could actually read all along?
Okay, how much more of the...
Oh, shit!
Nice.
Wait, so how much more of the game do I have left?
Chat?
Four hours.
Alright.
I have four hours left.
Hmm.
I'm like thinking.
Okay, okay, okay.
Someone said eight hours.
Okay, account for Doki time.
Doki time.
How many hours do I have left?
I know I have no right to ask.
Can you anyway?
One more stream.
Okay.
Why can you not tell me?
It's complicated.
What about you?
Why do you have a new weapon?
I thought you didn't want war.
I do not but all right, we'll do the last we'll do this
mission and then we'll call it There's a lot of yellow holy
fuck where where did my wife get all that yellow pain
Everyone keeps secrets Sometimes it's the only way to
protect the ones we love and don't worry about Odin.
I'm not going back there That is good to hear
Oh, we're in More dimension marks, claw marks, more portals.
I think I understand how Freya closed one.
Keep the enemies away if you can.
I can.
Let me know when you're ready.
I'm ready.
Let's do this.
I bet if we follow those hellwalkers up there, we find Garm.
How did he see me?
Oh shit.
Wait, how did he see me?
It's five.
I use my fist!
That's the last guy, right?
Oh my god, please, if you could just say those two words
faster.
Fuck it.
I fucking
run!
Get over here!
You don't matter!
That's right!
No one will remember you when you die.
Oh shit.
Whoops.
Technically you are already dead so no one's gonna remember
you when you're dead dead when you think about it.
But do I not have this power up?
Oh, I don't.
All right, give me a sec.
Oh my god, please boy.
Say it a little faster
Oh my god, he's ice Fire beats ice Oh my god, you're still
going I thought you finished What do you mean you're still
fucking shouting?
Oh my god.
There we go There we go I thought you finished last time,
whatever.
You didn't have to.
I am your father.
I will always help as long as I am able.
Well, that's good to hear, too.
Tell me, what were you doing in Asgard?
I was translating things for Odin.
There's this mask he found and a magical riff that's
connected to it.
It's all sort of...
Complicated.
Yeah, but I met people my age there.
Made friends.
You're kicking the undead while you're down.
and help don't be didn't have to go for me that's on them
they made the first move judgment maybe I'm tired of feeling
alone oh he just wants to hang out with people his own age
the
gears blocked when the gate is up okay okay
okay okay oh my god forgot he has arrows
what are you thinking maybe we can use my new arrows they
can chain element i forgot about it i forgot he has the
power of the power of arrows i've been working with freya
for so long i forgot that he can do this too I was like oh
yeah you also know magic I think we're gonna need more than
one sigil oh okay oh
okay wait
I need a way to transfer that freeze ability around the gate
maybe we can use my new arrows they can chain elements
there's my axe oh there it is
Oh my god, I made it just in time.
Oh, I gotta use my shames.
I'm gonna use this.
Fire bad!
Oh my god, they all want, oh my god, they were all like
worthy for combo.
But they, but I don't think they're worthy.
Yay, he is.
There he is.
Where's, who's he?
Oh, there he is.
He's carrying this whole realm apart.
Jesus.
I forgot about this ability.
How come?
Oh no.
You know what, I'm just gonna...
I'm just gonna do the slingy sling while I'm here.
That's where Arctea is!
You go!
Wait, where do I go?
Oh, there he is.
He seems pretty happy.
Okay, we'll go this way then.
Oh, yeah.
Ah, enemies are going to show up here, aren't they?
I was like, hmm, why is there a funny rock?
Yeah, I was thinking, like, hmm, I hope that rock is not
important.
That's awkward.
How am I?
Oh, here.
There it is.
what oh what the fuck
he's gonna use my fire since they're weak against fire and
your emma as well
yes easy is that all of them yeah i think so
That One trillion picks Oh what the fuck What the fuck Burn
you There you go That's fucking right I'm gonna do it again
Oh God fuck it
Pew pew Oh where's the Oh there he is Oh Oh
nice all right opening my chest that's why you don't disrupt
me when i'm opening my chest guys boom headshot peekaboo
series of blood with scorches nearby enemies tame the beast
what the fuck
oh shit yeah fuck yeah give me that three three plus damage
I do not want you to feel alone but your decision to go to
Asgard help me understand Odin doesn't want Ragnarok I know
I can't trust him but I needed his help why can't I climb
that too why do I need my son's help I would have helped you
you don't need to go to your stepdad what what can odin do
that i can't okay okay oh shit okay boy it's all right just
calm oh we just want to oh he's so scared he's been abused
for so long Oh That what the fuck who's this guy?
Oh shit wrong wrong ability Oh nice.
Well that was easy
God fuck it That's it That's fucking it.
Alright there we go.
Bye that.
Okay, that's the on him he should not have stood like at the
end of the cliff if he didn't want to fucking get kicked off
come on we can squeeze through here
Odin bought him an iPhone and you just told him to grow up
you're like no screen time bad for you if Odin truly wishes
to avoid Ragnarok then we are in agreement yeah what's you
have other weapons for that what the holy shit well i mean
that was i that works
holy fire is actually so strong against them
that was insane yeah i was mashing r2 was that did not look
like it i was mashing this and you You guys know I have a
fast trigger finger.
Traveler.
I hate fighting these guys when they're alive.
Don't seem that bad.
Oh.
Alright.
That's fine.
I'm gonna say like, oh, it seemed pretty weak and I realized
I have none of my upgrades.
I'm so mad!
And I fucking run!
See?
I told you they weren't that bad.
Oh fuck never mind.
He's still alive My god, he can't even hit back
Oh shit.
Oh my god, I didn't think you actually hit back
It's bad switching arrows There you go.
He got stun locked so hard Get out of here!
Are you overcompensating or some shit?
With that big ass sword?
If you're not preparing for Ragnarok.
I was like, to fight back, I was like, wait a minute.
I didn't mean for you to actually fight back.
We are not the same.
I am the parent.
You're ducking the question.
Look, I didn't think he'd actually do it, okay?
Oh, it's here.
Oh, he's here.
Looks like it's not vulnerable to sigil arrows.
What?
Oh, okay.
I think my arrows will stick to the wood up there.
Yay!
Let's go.
God, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Punching him a tight space.
Like, I'm pulling a nerd already in the locker.
Oh, we need free item.
We're close.
Are we?
You promise me you won't kill him.
Okay.
I make no promises, but I will try not to kill the beast.
Okay, I guess we go this way.
See here?
Or it's the big wolf.
Oh, well?
Oh, that I was gonna say there's no way this guy's alive.
Yeah, I fucking knew it.
Fucking knew you guys were playing today.
I was like, wow, two bodies just lying there suspiciously?
Yeah, a fucking course.
No way forward.
But looks like there's a notch in the wall.
I don't think I have an angle for this, do I?
You're spear fit into it?
Oops.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
an angle for that oh doesn't matter i guess i gotta figure
out an angle
oh oh there it is oops i just feel like r2 was the throw
button because that's usually what it is right whenever you
throw stuff it's r2 noah thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you
This is like shooting.
Oh, light runic.
Perform a fury of staffs with...
Press...
Oh, wait.
More damage.
Yeah, it's more damage.
And same cooldown.
So that should be better.
Alright.
What is your plan?
I'm sort of making it up as I go.
Oh, yay, freestyle.
You're not talking about Varm.
You cannot outsmart Odin.
It's worked so far.
Has it?
Oh, the players!
There's a snowball fight.
Never mind.
They just got murdered.
I was like, oh, that's cute.
It's like a snowball fight.
I'm going to try to tame it.
Tame it.
Tame it?
I've tamed wolves before.
I don't think that's a normal wolf.
is I don't know you see what I'm looking at but that does
not look like a normal
whoa all right let's grab these we need all the rage we can
get oh I fucking good what the fuck where the fuck did that
guy come from it's like two Third party time it's just a
bigger wolf.
It's like Clifford
Okay, I'll distract Garm you freezes change with your axe
and we can't run and latch him on to something I don't know.
Yeah, I was gonna say that doesn't let's move.
I'll feel like that will make him like oh my god What I'll
talk to him wolf by wolf wolf to wolf a heart to heart How
do I
There we go.
Grab the chain links before Garm can escape.
I did it!
Oh, I did it!
I was like, I did it!
I grabbed it with my axe!
Oh shit!
Oh, fuck.
Okay, are you okay?
Are you okay?
We almost...
Your transformation.
Did Odin teach you to control it?
No.
We will not rely on what he taught you next time.
Oh, forget everything he taught you.
Holy shit!
Oh my god, he's jealous.
He's so petty and jealous.
He's like, how dare you use the stuff that he taught you?
Damn.
That's crazy.
So where's my...
Yeah, I'll use this actually.
Oh my god, get the fuck away from me.
We're returning that iPhone.
Alright, nice.
Why didn't that work?
You didn't mess up on purpose.
Did you?
Okay, you saw me grab it.
Sorry.
I was gonna say it.
There's no way you just said that.
Patience.
We will find a way.
But I didn't know it.
There is always a way.
Found it.
Do you see?
Oh, why didn't I think of that?
The solution is not always obvious.
I mean, it was pretty obvious to me.
Boop.
Alright, now we do this.
Are you fucking- oh my- I hate her so much.
I hate her so much.
She just disappears!
Like, it's bullshit!
All she does is just disappear!
That's why I still lock you in the fucking corner.
That's right.
Oh my god, what the fuck?
Who are you?
We're part of this original fight
That's right, get stunlock get stunlocked.
This is a fighting game.
I got you in the corner We do this my way now.
I guess your way means it means what you think it means
Can't we try and we have the power to limit the harm this
creature can cause we will use it Okay, now she is so
annoying I'm glad I was able to like push her against the
fucking wall.
Oh, there you go.
Alright, tick two.
Can't get juggled.
Oh, what?
When I said tick two, I thought we were still gonna talk to
him.
Oh, no.
I didn't think I was actually a fight to die.
Oh, shit!
Oh, no!
Oh, I don't know my body.
I like this.
Holy fuck.
Oh, I got his paws.
It is beyond reason, Atreus.
Oh, Ness.
Okay, I didn't think I was gonna...
Okay.
I don't know if I like this, but okay.
Got him!
You leave us no choice.
We didn't want to do this, boy!
We try to talk to you nice and fair!
Oh, man.
This is fucking Chris.
What the fuck?
That's right.
Okay.
Yes, let's see why they locked him up now.
Yeah, now you can tell.
Yeah, yeah, no.
He's not very happy right now.
Yeah.
Do not show mercy.
Oh, shit.
Okay, that's my bad.
That is my bad.
Can I even hit him?
I don't think I can.
Okay, there we go.
That's right.
God damn he dodged it.
Holy shit.
Looks like he's getting ready to attack.
All right, dodge, dodge, dodge.
Oh, he's hacking up another hairball, I guess.
What the?
That was not in my fucking...
That was not in the red paint right there.
Excuse me.
Okay.
Okay,
nice.
Alright, I don't trust myself here.
I'm just gonna...
He's gonna wait.
All he does...
Jesus Christ.
Oh, my gosh.
Still fucked it up.
So...
Oh, shit.
I gotta be angry.
I gotta start punching the dog.
I gotta do this.
It's me or him.
I need my HP, guys.
I really need my HP.
No, I just can't.
Let's just move, or just moving the stout, guys.
Dude, I'm just moving the stout.
Understandable.
Okay.
I'm pulling, I'm pulling, I'm pulling.
Arteez, please!
I don't know what you're gonna do, but please!
Oh my god, now I have to press the square!
Please, Arteez, please, we trade for this!
Oh!
Is she alive?
It is over.
I wish it didn't have to end that way.
Hello?
It's my fault he got loose.
That he's dead.
Hello?
Sometimes there is no.
No other way.
Oh.
This is bad.
You did this joke.
I did it.
No.
I thought we were just gonna choke.
We need him!
I thought we were still...
Oh no!
Can we just go home now?
I know.
Close my heart to it.
Aww.
I didn't think we were actually gonna kill him.
I thought...
I really thought...
Oh no!
What do I do?
Oh my god.
That's fucked.
Maybe we can use my sigils to carry the frost to the gear.
Nice.
I thought like, you know, we're still gonna have a talk.
Go before it unfreezes.
I didn't know.
guys I thought we're still gonna have a toxic thing maybe
he's maybe he like fainted maybe we gave him a chokehold no
how do we know if he's actually dead guys come on come on he
could be he could have fainted Jack oh shit what I told you
I told you I told you he fainting he fainting he fainting
we're not bad people you don't know oh my god oh my god i
wasn't wrong i knew it oh shit oh my god not dead not dead
not a not a bad person not a criminal thank god oh thank god
i fucking knew it oh shit that's cool that's sick that was
sick dog alive he was just very eepy guys oh hello oh shit
oh shit um oh shit i did not think all right hello i guess
round two oh what oh i was just like do i i'm not just gonna
beat up the dog again
I told you guys I knew I wasn't a bad person see I was just
trying to make him I was just trying to paint him all right
if we can't find him the dead will keep flooding the realms
the realms will collapse you must learn to calm your I told
y 'all I was just giving him a hug.
Just giving him a really tight hug.
Because he didn't feel a lot of love back then.
Oh, fuck.
Guys, I don't think he liked my hug.
I think he's very, very mad about that hug.
Oh.
fuck round two.
Wait, now we fight?
What the fuck was that before?
What do you mean now we fight?
I was gonna say, what the fuck do you mean?
Now we fight.
I thought we were already fighting.
Okay.
All right Just give up
Okay What the fuck how did I hit?
Oh fuck come on.
That's not cool There we go Stay down
That's fucking right.
Stay down, boy!
Stay down!
Oh my god, he's so close.
I could see that.
How does he keep that back?
Wait, what?
That is his nature.
We gotta change that.
How do we change his nature?
What do you mean?
Wait, I think I can stop this.
How?
I need you to help me get on his back.
How the fuck?
Please, I got this.
with it how the fuck are you gonna do that okay like how
that's easier said than done boy okay that is not cool okay
are you gonna get on the dogs back or not boy don't you want
to rest oh my god I don't know how there you go This is it!
This is it!
Get on the dog's back!
Alright, right here!
Oh,
I could dock the shockwaves?
Oh man, I wish I knew that earlier.
Oh shit!
Please work, please work, please work!
He's drifting.
What the fuck?
Did I just knife his brain?
what the fuck did I do what happened yeah we gotta find him
come on what the fuck you just stabbed him in the brain what
the fuck did my son do that was a sick wheelie though on the
chain if he came this way let's find another way up what did
you do at the house the spell you saw me do in Fenner die I
didn't know it then, but I accidentally threw a stone to my
knife.
Did I transfer my dog so oh It's nature.
Yeah, let's see if it took oh my god I can fed you a new
body Now I have a big I have a big dog now You said you
needed to protect me.
Why I saw prophecy You were
That is so smart.
I saw it too.
In Jotunheim.
You knew?
That's why you've been training me so hard.
One day, you will have to survive without me.
Not gonna happen.
I won't let it.
What's that trick called when you skateboard on the chain?
Or like, on a handrail.
Not like that.
Is that, because my son just did that, was pretty rad.
oh oh my god yeah he was grinding oh
sorry i hurt you it's over now i promise oh he's a good boy
oh my god that's fenya god
he's so big now
oh my god it's so cute i missed you too didn't know if that
would work he's like i gotta tell you about dog heaven it's
real we did it dog heaven is real when you want to stay in
dog heaven though oh my god he's so big it's possible it's
giant magic Graham was, like, soulless, right?
He is so cute.
Oh, yeah.
He was in the dagger the whole time.
That's why Graham didn't listen to us.
Oh.
That's why his eyes were, like, pure white, too.
Like the other soulless animals we saw.
Oh my god, what the fuck?
Wait, we have the fastest fast travel.
Oh, he left us.
Okay, then you could have, you know, waited for us.
That is...
Okay, the teleporting dog didn't teleport us with him.
That is so cute.
Yeah, Pro could have given us a ride.
You know, after we brought him back to reality.
Oh my god.
It was like when Arteus put a fucking soul into a snake.
That means the giant was actually like, what the fuck?
Why am I in a snake's body?
I was promised like
so they do know what the fuck is going on.
Arteus, that's fucked up when you put a soul into snake's
body.
I just assumed the snake would still be like acting like a
snake but like that giant was 100% aware like he was
definitely self-aware yeah because I was like okay that's
fucked up our chance but I'm like maybe the giant like you
know maybe he he's he just he's just a snake now but no he
that's pretty fucked up man great it's open maybe we can use
the sigils to freeze the gear up there Edward actually is
don't hate me don't you answer thank you let's super chat he
said thank you thank you bro what the fuck I'm a snake now
yeah bro that's that's pretty fucked up bro how
do I do it on the other side though I think we're
Yeah, but...
What?
Oh, there.
That's actually so messed up.
Because if Venio, like, actually came back.
When it comes to your life, I can take no chances.
I'm surprised the chat just wad up for how messed up that
wake-up.
I don't think he must have been that way.
Like, I don't even know.
I don't even know how to react in that situation at that
point.
I just guess I just slither away.
I'm like, I guess this is my life now.
Like, you just woke up as a snake.
And you just gotta accept it.
You can't even talk.
I go to here?
Oh shit, that's a giant bird.
Do I have any more souls?
Should we talk to her?
Wait, is she also soulless?
Hello?
I was like, why is there a giant bird here?
Who put a giant bird?
that bird too jesus
she says there's six tears to close and uh not to expect
things they shouldn't have been open in the first place she
is not wrong oh does she want uh besides she watched from
afar now by recent When we have opened six tiers to hell,
um...
She is not pleased.
Alright.
Well.
You cannot deal with that.
Oh, he woke up blind, too.
Oh, yeah, I forgot.
Snakes are blind.
Oh, yeah.
He's like...
Maybe he didn't even know.
He didn't even know there are people in front of him.
Bro, Arteus.
I think you fucked over that guy.
life no arms no legs blind that's now a snake like where did
my arms go
what's wrong
huh angry I mean I'm justified to be angry oh there's a
pretty bad guy he's
an asshole Oh
Chased you away.
Oh
Without you I got reckless Overconfident Me stupid mistakes
I don't know why I thought I could do this alone
You were right no no son
on our journey together you have grown to a warrior worthy
of your namesake i was the one who was not ready oh wasn't
ready for him to grow up to be who you were just because he
still sees him as his boy
for your voice in my head when you're not there to guide me
and you do the same all right
oh my god i need father potter son bonding
the raven in the background i am
sorry Don't be sorry, father.
Be better.
Oh.
Learn from our mistakes.
There's always time to improve.
As a father and a son.
That's so touching.
Oh, and their bond grew stronger.
And they have a new dog!
Nothing is written.
That can't be a new dog.
Oh my god.
We shouldn't let prophecy things can only go up then we will
make our own destiny We won't let fate tell us what to do I
bet fate did oh XP.
I bet fate didn't know expect us to get a giant ass dog
Holy shit.
That's a lot of strength I lose Yeah, no, I'll keep this
That mmm I feel like I should upgrade my rage.
Yeah, I'm gonna upgrade my rage.
Oh my god.
And my dog came back to life.
I want to keep the runic.
I feel like my runic is already really good in general.
It's my amulet.
Truly, this is data boy.
Wait, Rabbit, thank you for Super Chat.
Thank you.
yeah they made up they got back their new old dog and loki
has three girls friends things are looking up really is is
there anything else i can upgrade and i want oh yeah i
wanted to upgrade uh
oh yeah this
yeah let's actually oh i don't have enough all right let's
grab this
all right that should be good wait more oh
oh i want drink and apply moderate burn
i'll do oh i don't have enough Oh, I have one XP left.
Holy shit.
All right.
I was like, how much XP do I have?
One.
Did you want to take care of anything before going back to
Sindri's?
No.
First, we retrieve Mamir.
Then you can tell us what you learned in Asgard.
Solid.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
Big, goodest boy over new iPhone anytime.
Love me some father-son bonding stories.
Thank you.
Super chat.
to odin yeah the relationship is so what's the word really
sweet i tried convincing her of that but when was that oh
before i started telling you where i was like you know after
they made up and everything before then it was pretty
traumatic but like now now it's like wholesome now it's
pretty wholesome before then i will say their their
relationship was pretty traumatic slash a little bit abusive
but now it's better now it's a lot better yeah they
definitely grew a lot as characters
yeah that's character development you got better at
parenting
hello hello everyone you're back how did it go ruby should
trouble us no further well that's a bloody relief so you put
down old garm did you yeah sort of atreus your decision to
go to after all he's put us through I'll never understand it
but I hope you at least came back with something we can use
I hope so too come on let me show you what Odin's up to no
here's what he cares about most more than Ragnarok or
anything is this mask anyone recognize it that thing oh it's
dead end he's been faffing around with that since before i
knew him why isn't he looking honest i thought the giants
were just having a laugh with that one wait he knows okay
fine but he knows about the mask oh you're wrong amir this
mask is no fraud the giants didn't make it and only a few of
them ever glimpsed it in origin but some believed it was a
way to gaze into the secrets of creation itself is it an
oracle much much more
imagine becoming one with a source of infinite knowledge
this this is why odin tortured me
oh so that's how odin found out about the mass now what no
it no it's one obsession he never saw fit to share with me
but I'll tell you this even when Odin speaks the truth his
purpose is false either way it's a mistake to let it
distract us is Heimdall our focus or not we will rewrite our
fate then i'm going back to vanaheim huh if we're not taking
the fight to odin i should help my brother stand against him
but is this not what the what if this is what the fate
foresaw like we don't know what we do lead us to the
prophecy anything can lead us to it i'm gonna study my notes
on the mask see if i can think of a plan travel if you want
to go anywhere i'm with you and listen everyone where's the
wolf sorry about the way i left you know i've never heard
any of you on purpose well when you can turn into a bear by
accident i suppose these things can happen so do you forgive
me of course atreus we know you meant no harm He's just a
kid.
I'm sure I will.
Guess I'll take it.
While we're clearing the air, I hope that I can be forgiven
for not doing more when the Hellwalkers attacked.
Whatever reservations I have about violence, they shouldn't
apply when your home is under attack.
And certainly not by undead abomination.
He's at the old house?
God damn it!
I reached for a shield instead of a sword.
You are right to chide me for that, old friend.
Why are we always going back to the wrong house?
I'll be ready.
Well said, Tia.
I believe you just might.
Oh, yeah, sure.
He did grab a shield.
He's like, he's like, don't worry, guys, I'm here.
I'm just going to keep working on this till you're ready to
head out.
Can't believe it.
My dog is also at the wrong house.
He wouldn't fit there.
We can put him outside.
I think I need to clear my head.
I don't know that.
You can fit outside the house.
Thank you.
Alright, let's see.
Oh, another upgrade.
Keep her sharp and she'll keep you alive.
Oh, and I have an upgrade for this too?
Ooh.
Nice.
Okay, that's all the upgrades I have.
Uh...
Defense is lower.
Vitality.
I don't know if I like that.
I'm gonna keep my current stuff then.
Before we check on Freya, is there any unfinished business
in other realms you want to take care of?
I'm sure the lad would love to help.
No, that's okay.
Wait.
We're with you.
Like, nope.
All right.
We're good.
Off to Vanaheim.
Where is it?
I just had to go here.
Freya's camp?
We traveled to Vanaheim.
Great.
You gonna check in on Freya?
Oh my god, I saw the dog.
I should have fucking went to the dog.
Oh shit.
So what happened the last time you were in Vanahe?
Wait.
I still don't know how you got Frey to stop trying to kill
you.
We traveled to her village to break Odin's spell.
Once freed, she accepted that I was not her enemy.
You also missed a highly entertaining moment where Brock was
lifted ass over face and Frey's down.
Oh yeah, I could go back, right?
What's he like?
Different from his sister.
Lacks her conviction.
True.
But he's a bit quicker to forgive.
I don't want to go back.
In effect.
Good leader.
I just restart checkpoint?
him lad is that all i have to do
i'm gonna load in
oh i can travel back what i get oh there is the door what
the fuck why did it spawn back here
okay all right we're going back it's beautiful and uh what
it is also dangerous more dangerous
all right here you go it's right behind me isn't it all
right let's go to map where is my
let's hear it no that's hell that's why it's called hell m
midgard there you go where is my where is midgard yeah but
where is it
Where does my dog sleep?
Upper wilderness?
Oh, that was fast.
Where's my dog?
Hello?
Hello, boy?
Where's my good boy?
Wait, where is he?
Where's my dog?
Hello?
Doggo?
Where the fuck's my dog?
Oh, he's not here yet?
God fucking damn it.
Is he traveling between dimensions right now?
Maybe he went for a walk.
A fucking course he is he's still like he's still learning
his new powers Yeah, he's like He's he's getting his will
he's getting his dimension walking right now He hasn't
pooped in a long time.
He journeyed across Agia's bundling ocean into the heart of
the silent mate and herself Quick guys we got follow report
to the ring cameras All that blood and more.
Guys, we gotta search him up in the ring cameras, guys.
We have a missing dog.
He's gotta mark all the trees and the dimensions.
Oh, nope.
Alright.
I think this is a good time to stop here.
How much progress did we make?
Like, where are we at right now, chat?
Ring cam in all nine realms.
75% done.
Do you think I can finish it next stream?
Guys?
How much more of the gameplay do we have left?
Like, hours left!
I don't know if I can play eight hours.
75%?
I mean, 75% is pretty good progress.
I did not think we were getting actually closer.
Maybe two streams?
Oh, man.
Do you think I can take eight hours?
Ooh.
Like, Like, one, maybe two streams.
I'll try one stream and then we'll see how far it goes.
Maybe.
I'll see.
I'll schedule one stream for it and then, like, um, and then
we'll see how that goes.
But I'm definitely enjoying this game a lot.
Um, I love, I really love how the story is progressing.
And I think it's so well-written, honestly.
And, like, it feels so real.
Like, some of the dialogue is so well-written.
And, like, it feels like...
actual like the the interactions and the voice acting is
just so so really good like everybody too like when we were
talking hearing like thor and his wife talking and i'm like
oh my god this feels too real like this feels like something
i've heard before like in other shows um and how he's like
you can't let your father control you i'm like oh my god
he's like you gotta stop the cycle yeah um and i've been
enjoying yeah i've been enjoying how immersive everything is
so far for watching everybody tomorrow is my rest day but
i'll be back for dad's birthday on saturday so uh thank you
all for watching guys it's been a wonderful journey with god
warm so far um and as always everybody stay hydrated posture
check get them around to get that blood flowing and if you
suffer me head to bed because you deserve it i'll see you
guys next time everybody bye guys